bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pour suivre dans un
instant l'audition d'Emmanuel Kos la
ministre du Logement qui s'est exprimée
hier devant les sénateurs réunis en
commission spéciale à l'occasion de la
préparation du projet de loi égalité et
citoyenneté un texte qui a été adopté la
semaine der derère à l'Assemblée
nationale en première lecture et qui
vise à favoriser l'insertion des jeunes
pour cela il s'articule autour de trois
volets l'émancipation des jeunes et la
généralisation de l'engagement du
service de l'intérêt général la mixité
sociale et l'égalité d'accès au logement
et enfin le renforcement de l'égalité
réelle c'est sur le deuxième volet que
la ministre du Logement est intervenue
et vous allez le voir plusieurs
dispositions du projet de loi ont pour
objectif de forcer les communes à
construire 20 à 25 % de logements
sociaux minimum ce qui a suscité bien
des réactions notamment des sénateurs de
la droite voyez tout de suite leurs
échanges avec Emmanuel C l'ordre du jour
appelle l'audition de Madame Emmanuelle
cosos ministre du logement et de
l'habitat durable comme je vous le
disais madame les ministre en fait vous
êtes la première personne et chacun le
comprend à être auditionné dans le cadre
de la commission
spéciale nous avons deux volets qui sont
concernés par ce texte volet logement
pour lequel Dominique Estrosi est
rapporteur je je le lui confirme je le
lui confirme pardon et puis Françoise
Gatel j'ai le plaisir de lui confirmer
aussi qu'elle est rapporteur et de façon
officielle du texte pour la partie qui
relève du ministère de la
Culture j'aurai l'occasion après
l'audition de Madame KOF de vous
rappeler le calendrier d'un certain
nombre de réunions qui auront lieu il y
a bien sûr les auditions des rapporteurs
mais aussi des réunions à des dates qui
sont pas forcément celles
auxquelles vous vous attendiez mais nous
avons un travail considérable à mener et
il est clair que le Sénat doit marquer
de son empreinte ce texte important
madame la
ministre je vais vous donner la parole
maintenant dans dans un instant je
rappelle que vous défendez le projet de
loi égalité citoyenneté en fait avec
plusieurs de vos collègues Patrick caner
qui est ministre de la viille de la je
eSport et c'est bien entendu le le le
volet qui concerne notamment Françoise
Gattel et Madame Éric barrec qui est
secrétaire d'État chargé de l'égalité
réelle que nous entendrons la semaine
prochaine vous êtes plus
particulièrement en charge du volet
logement dont le nombre d'articles a été
multiplié par
4,5 ce n'est pas de votre faitte
d'ailleurs je le dis tout de suite pour
vous absoudre un petit peu mais bon faut
avouer est à demi pardonn mais je pense
que la faute Inc plus certain nombre de
parlementaires je ne dis pas de quel
groupe il s'agit mais tout état de cause
le texte a évidemment beaucoup gonflé et
le volet logement est passé de 14
articles lors de son dépôt à 63 après
examen par l'Assemblée nationale alors
ce volet aborde plusieurs sujets parmi
lesquels un certain nombre auquels nous
prêtons une particulière attention c'est
les attributions de logement sociaux le
dispositif de l'article 55 de la loi SRU
l'accueil des gens du voyage
le supplément de loyer de solidarité ou
encore les relations entre les bailleurs
sociaux et les
locataires alors il serait intéressant
madame la ministre que vous puissiez
nous
indiquer dans un premier temps vous êtes
évidemment tout à fait libre d'organiser
votre propos comme vous l'entendez mais
que vous nous disiez au fond ce qui a
changé par le travail de l'Assemblée
nationale entre le texte que nous
connaissions et sur lequel d'ailleurs
nos rapporteurs avaient commencé à
travailler et puis finalement le texte
qui est S sorti il y a peu de temps de
l'Assemblée nationale cet exercice un
peu pédagogique nous sera fort utile
pour bien comprendre les choses madame
la ministre je vous laisse la
parole merci monsieur le Président et
merci de m'auditionner aujourd'hui je
suis ravie de venir vous présenter le
texte de loi tel qu'il est ressorti des
discussions à l'Assemblée nationale je
voulais aussi vous remercier votre
implication mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs sur ce texte de
loi parce qu'en effet c'est un texte de
loi qui est
important qui est vaste qui comprend des
discussions sur des sujets extrêmement
différents qui font appel à à évidemment
beaucoup de compétences différentes et
en même temps qui me semble extrêmement
important le texte de loi moi j'aihitude
de le dire parce parce qu'il comporte en
effet un volet sur le logement important
mais je tiens à le rappeler je vous
l'avais dit d'ailleurs en commission
quand itionné euh c'est pas un texte de
loi sur le logement c'est plutôt une
discussion
sur la question de la mixité sociale
dans l'habitat et de ce fait cela amène
à des propositions de modification
législative mais il me semble-t-il c'est
aussi une des premières fois où on peut
avoir une discussion au niveau du
Parlement sur les questions de mixité
sociale question de peuplement dans nos
quartiers la question de la ségrégation
territoriale et comment elle s'est
exercé à travers des politiques de
logement et ça a d'ailleurs amené pour
tout vous dire à des débat à l'Assemblée
nationale très long et en même temps
très intéressant et qui allit d'ailleurs
au-delà des questions de clivage
politique assez caricaturaux que nous
pourrions connaître et sur lequel ça
aussi permis me semble-t-il d'avoir en
commission spéciale et après en séance
plainèire un débat très important ce
texte de loi égalité
citoyenneté s'inscrit très clairement
dans l'esprit des textes de loi que vous
avez eu à étudier ces dernières années
évidemment la loi allure avant la loi
mobilisation pour le foncier public mais
au-delà de ça euh on retrouve la suite
de la mise en œuvre de la loi SRU bien
entendu aussi des dispositifs de la loi
molle qui sont améliorés et donc
s'inscrit me semble-t-il dans euh la la
volonté de compléter cette ce texte
législatif mais aussi de l'améliorer
très clairement et de donner des moyens
aux collectivités de bien travailler sur
ces questions de mixité sociale à partir
de là c'est objectif de mixité sociale
se
traduisent dans le le le titre le titre
2 sur en gros trois chapitres qui
concerne les attributions de logements
sociaux la question des la possibilité
d'avoir une nouvelle politique de loyer
pour les bailleurs sociaux et enfin la
l'application et le renforcement de
l'application des dispositions liées à
la loi SRU et donc à la question de la
production mais il est vrai que on s'est
beaucoup attaché sur les politiques de
logement depuis longtemps à travailler
sur les questions de produ et là on
regarde plutôt sur les questions de de
l'usage et donc du peuplement et
évidemment de la manière dont on peut
répondre à ces questions de de mixité à
partir de là pour vous donner un peu
l'esprit du texte tel qu'il en ressort
première grande mesure du texte de loi
concernait les attributions de logements
sociaux et
notamment un principe qui qui est issu
des travaux qui ont été menés dans les
comités interministériel pour l'égalité
la citoyenneté il y en a eu trois
notamment lors du second a été beaucoup
discuté de la concentration de la
pauvreté dans certains territoires euh
et donc de regarder comment est-ce que
l'on peut mieux agir d'une part pour
lutter contre la pauvreté qui me
semble-t-il un premier sujet mais aussi
de travailler euh à à ce que cette
pauvreté ne soit pas autant concentré et
une des mesures qui a été proposées
c'est de pré voir que 25 % des
attributions des logements sociaux
déménag du premier qutil donc déménages
qu'on les revenus les plus faibles se
fassent hors quartier politique de la
ville c'est 25 % vous pourriez me dire
un chiffre important en fait c'est une
attribution sur quatre et il est très
important de dire que
c'est la volonté de ramener un équilibre
notamment hors des quartiers politiques
de la ville alors cette mesure elle a
évidemment beaucoup de débats d'une part
sur le
principe parce qu'en fait en inscrivant
cette mesure dans le texte de loi nous
avons aussi pu montrer que finalement
aujourd'hui bah on est évidemment sur
des chiffres qui sont assez éloignés
alors ça dépend évidemment des
territoires et ici et aussi des de
données que nous avons pour pouvoir
renseigner ces questions là des données
avec des données que nous avons on s'est
rendu compte qu'au niveau national
semble-t-il il il y a 19 % des
attributions qui sont en quartier
politique de la ville pour les ménages
du premier quartil 19 % mais après quand
on regarde sur certains territoires on
se rend compte que ça peut descendre
très vite à 5 % ou à 6 % ce qui veut
dire à contrario que c'est 80 % 9 % des
attributions en quartier politique de la
ville qui se font pour les ménages du
premier quartil et il me semble
important de le dire mais on a vu aussi
des collectivités qui sont capables de
faire 30 % donc on voit bien qu'on a des
réalités territoriales qui sont qui sont
très différentes et donc ça explique une
des modifications qui a été faite lors
de la discussion à l'Assemblée nationale
avec mon aval c'est que nous avons
souhaité derrière le principe de 25 %
qu'il y ait un travail local sur ce
principe et donc
euh beaucoup de
modifications à l'Assemblée nationale
pent sur le fait que nous avons voulu
associé et même donné à le PCI par le
biais de la conférence intercommunale du
logement le rôle de travailler sur ce
pourcentage d'attribution et d'avoir une
discussion au sein de le PCI sur en fait
la politique de peuplement et ce qui
explique tous les dispositifs que nous
avons mis en donc fixant un un principe
simple le principe c'est 25 % il peut y
avoir une adaptation locale s'il y a un
accord élaboré entre la conférence
intercommunale du logement donc approuvé
par le président de le PCI et le préfet
et dans ce cas-là un un pourcentage qui
peut être révisé tous tous les 3 ans ça
a permis aussi en dotant vraiment le
territoire en fait de cette mise en
œuvre cela nous a permis aussi de
répondre à un deuxième sujet qui a
beaucoup occupé nos discussions qui est
que euh on a donc voulu mettre un
principe de de d'attribution hors des
quartiers politiques de la ville la
question s'est posée est-ce qu'on peut
limiter l'entrée de certains ménages
dans les quartiers politiques de la
ville c'est un débat qui m'a pas mal
opposé euh avec euh avec des députés non
pas sur le constat euh on partage le
constat qu'il y a aujourd'hui en
quartier politique de la ville euh
souvent une facilité des uns et des
autres à parfois euh euh concentrer les
attributions de logements sociaux et
compris des ménages les plus en
difficulté il y avait été proposé en
commission spéciale qu'il y ait un
plafonnement et que par exemple on
plafonne euh les attributions de ménag
prioritaire ou de dalallo à 50 % en
quartier politique de la ville je m'y
suis opposé euh pour une raison qui
était le fait qu'il me semblait très
autant il me semblait possible de
défendre la volonté d'ouvrir d'autres
quartiers et donc d'avoir une
proposition en positif autant il me
semblait compliqué d'expliquer à des
ménages en difficulté que dépasser un
côté ils n'ont plus le droit d'avoir une
attribution de logement social et y
compris au nom d'une part d'une loi sur
laquelle vous avez travaillé ainsi
queocénat qui a été adopté depuis qui
est la loi qui parle de la
discrimination fondée sur la précarité
sociale qui quand même dit des choses
très fortes sur cette questionl mais
aussi parce que me semble-t-il quel
serait le signe que l'on enverrait si on
explique en gros à des ménages qui sont
reconnus par la Constitution prioritaire
au relogement c'est le cas des do
qu'est-ce que ça voudrait dire si on
leur disait que par ailleurs on peut
limiter l'accès de ce droit
prioritaire et donc on a beaucoup cogité
avec les députés sur cette question pour
trouver néanmoins une manière de
travailler sur ces questions de
peuplement et de positiver cette
questionl et nous nous sommes mis
d'accord et c'est ce qui résulte en fait
du texte au final parce que derrière
cette ce plafond le le le débat qui qui
ressortait c'était l'absence de
discussion locale sur cette questionl
l'absence de discussion entre maire
membbrre de leepci réservatair bailleurs
sociaux préfets et donc il fallait
trouver un moyen de d'avancer et donc
nous avons fait le choix de trouver un
un un compromis pour éviter ces
plafonnements à l'entrée des quartiers
politiques de la ville en souhaitant
d'une part qu'il y ait une commission de
désignation dans les quartiers en
politique de la ville qui inclut
réservataire bailleurs et élu pour
pouvoir justement discuter ensemble de
ces questions de de peuplement et une
commission qui va nous permettre
évidemment de donner des des déjà d'une
part des indic et l'autre chose parce
que il me semble aussi que les questions
de mixité sociale indiquent aussi qu'on
doit travailler sur attirer de nouveau
publics dans les quartiers et donc notre
objectif est de pouvoir inscrire dans le
travail qui sera donc mené au sein des
conférences intercommunales des
pourcentages par exemple de relogement
de jeunes actifs
d'étudiants de familles et et de
salariés puisque c'est en gros cela le
sujet la mixité sociale c'est aussi
amener différentes personnes dans ces
log
des des familles qui évidemment rentrent
dans les plafonds du logement du
logement social et donc seront inscrits
dans les orientations fixées par la
Conférence
intercommunale des objectifs de
relogement des publics qui
n'appartiennent pas au premier quartil
et donc nous avons voulu prendre en
compte cette question là mais en la
positivant et en essayant de traduire de
manière positif ce que pourrait être les
questions de mixité de mixité sociale ça
c'est sur le premier sujet qui nous a
beaucoup occupé le deuxième il y a eu un
long débat sur la question de la
définition de qu'est-ce qu'un public
prioritaire et qu'est-ce qui relève du
droit au logement
opposable là-dessus et on a eu un grand
nombre de débats la volonté a été très
clairement de ma part de ne pas élargir
la définition des publics reconnu par
enfin en tant que que d'Allo qui nous
semble être aujourd'hui une liste
importante qui reconnaît des situation
qui nécessit un relogement posable et
donc des situations assez extrêmes mais
par contre nous avons porté quelques
modifications sur les publics 10
prioritaire en sachant que quand même et
je j'alerte toujours tout le monde sur
le
sujet il y a une volonté d'élargir les
publics prioritaires à des tas de
catégories de de de personnes avec très
souvent des très bonnes des tout à fait
bonnes raisons et en même temps il faut
qu'on fasse évidemment attention à ne
pas élargir trop la liste des publics
prioritaires parce que plus on l'élargit
plus il y a des gens à reloger au titre
du public prioritaire ça veut dire que
les gens deviennent beaucoup moins
prioritaires je le dis parce que
notamment j'ai repoussé des amendement
qui voulait par exemple intégrer les
jeunes comme public prioritaire et si je
ne mésestime pas par exemple les
difficultés de logement de jeunes je ne
crois pas que c'est l'âge qui en fait un
public prioritaire sinon on pourrait
aussi penser que des personnes qui sont
à la retraite relèvent aussi d'un public
prioritaire ce qui relève de la priorité
c'est une une situation de de d'urgence
de grande précarité sociale et là-dessus
me semble-t-il il faut évidemment que
nous soyons prudents si on veut répondre
à nos objectifs je rappelle que le
relogement des publics prioritaires le
relogement de dalallo sont intégrés très
clairement par des obligations de
relogement très fortes donc voilà pour
euh pour ces sujets-là sur le 2è
chapitre euh concerne beaucoup je rentre
pas en détail parce que je pense que
vous aurez des questions et j'y
répondrai évidemment 2è chapitre c'est
sur la politique du loyer euh je le
rappelle il ne s'agit pas de permettre à
des bailleurs d'augmenter leur loyer
donc je le dis ici très clair il s'agit
de permettre à masse de loyers constante
de permettre à des bailleurs
de échanger la territorialisation de
certains logements et donc de se d'avoir
de se couper des modes de financement de
leur logement lorsqu'ils ont été
construits en clair de pouvoir à un
endroit transformer un plai en plus ou
en PLS un autre endroit de transformer
un pls en plus ou en plai je le Red dit
c'est à masse de loyer constant c'est
une possibilité qui est donnée au
bailleurs et en aucun cas évidemment une
obligation cela peut leur permettre de
remettre de la mixité dans des blocs
d'immeubles où ils n'en ont pas l'autre
sujet sur ce chapitre a évidemment été
le
surloyer qui nous a beaucoup beaucoup
occupé notre volonté était de durcir le
surloyer mais en même temps de répondre
à ce qui a été soulevé à plusieurs
reprises par les parlementaires qui est
que avoir une application trop stricte
du surloyer fait sortir de manière trop
rapide et trop dure des personnes qui
ont une évolution une évolution
salariale et de situation mais en même
temps ne les mettent pas non plus dans
une situation très absolument
confortable sur ce point-là ce qui a été
décité on ne change pas une bonne partie
des conditions d' celoyer tes que c'est
actuellement nous avons décidé que la
question euh du droit au
maintien euh et pardon déjà que le
plafond
maximum de la Somme loyer plus sur loyer
sera à 30 % il a été discuté que la
perte du maintien du droit au maintien
dans les lieux qui était le sujet le
plus
important jusque-là il s'exerçait sur
l'idée de 200 % du plafond du logement
dans lequel on est 200 % du plafond plai
plus ou pls nous avons décidé d'avoir la
même règle pour tout le monde
c'est-à-dire 150 % du du plafond pls et
notamment c'est pour tout vous dire les
choses ça a un avant ça a un effet
positif c'est que ça redonne de la marge
pour les gens qui étaient en plai parce
que nous voyons qu'il y avait une
certaine inéquité entre des personnes
qui donc rentrent un moment dans un
logement pli donc avec des ressources
très faibles mais se voit un jour
appliquer le surloyer parce qu'ils ont
une évolution professionnelle positive
et on peut on peut évidemment s'en
réjouir mais en même temps il reste
quand même sur des revenus assez bas par
contre quand vous êtes au pls on est
quand même sur des plafonds beaucoup
plus élevés je rappelle que euh c'est
quand même un un niveau de revenu bien
plus élevé quand vous êtes à 200 % du
pls paremple à Paris ça veut dire vous
êtes à plus de 5000 € net mensuel ce qui
est pas du tout le cas du revenu par
exemple du pli et donc on s'est rendu
compte qu'en fait là où le surloyer est
exercé je rappelle que ça concerne à peu
près que 4000 à 5000 locataires du
logement social il est plus durement
appliqué chez les locataires qui ont les
plus faibles revenus donc c'est pour ça
que nous avons accepté de moduler et de
modifier notre notre question sur les
surloyés enfin dernier chapitre c'est la
question du renforcement de la loi
SRU en rappelant évidemment que on est
donc déjà dans une évolution de de de
cette loi depuis les dispositions de la
loi sur le mobilisation foncier public
comme je vous l'avais dit en commission
je crois il y a quelques temps l'étude
d'impact nous avons montrer que si
toutes les communes déficitaires et
carencé produisaient les logements
qu'elles doivent produire d'ici 2025
c'est entre 700000 et 750000 logements
sociaux qui doivent être produits ce qui
n'est pas rien euh euh très très
clairement et donc les dispositions de
lois SRU sont surtout des moyens
supplémentaires donnés à l'état pour
appliquer la loi et notamment dans les
communes dans les communes carencé et
puis il y a eu une disposition et vous
le savez qui a été adoptée par la
assassemblée nationale que j'ai mis en
en alerte sur les conséquences de cette
position qui est la suppression de la
DSU pour les communes
carencé j'ai alerté sur les impacts très
importants que ça représente d'un point
de vue financier mais l'assemblée
national a voulu poursuivre poursuivre
dans dans ce sens et puis ensuite il y a
un autre débat je pense qu'on en parlera
tout à l'heure qui est des mesures de
simplification dans la fin du titre avec
des d'une part des questions
d'ordonnance mais il y a aussi pas mal
de disp disosition de simplification qui
sont intégrées dans le texte de
loi bien merci Madame le Ministre pour
votre propos extrêmement riche très
précis je vais sans tarder donner la
parole à nos deux rapporteurs tout
d'abord à Dominique estrzui ensuite à
Françoise Gatel alors question
d'organisation je donne un peu plus de
temps au rapporteurs ce qui sera compris
par chacun et ensuite il y aura une
règle très stricte qui est de minutes
par intervenant mais ça ne s'applique
pas la ministre bien sûr pour sa
réponse merci monsieur le Président
Madame la la ministre alors même si vous
avez dit au démarrage de votre propos
qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'un nouveau
projet de loi traitant de la politique
de l'habitat et du logement néanmoins
fallait-il de nouveau un texte de loi
dans lequel un gros chapitre est
consacré effectivement à la politique du
logement de l'habitat et à la mixité
sociale après et vous les avez avez cité
tout au long de votre propos un certain
nombre de lois et de dispositions
réglementaires qui sont venues depuis
les dernières années parler des
politiques de l'habitat et du logement
vous les avez cité c'est la loi SRU
c'est la loi allure c'est la loi
programmation pour la ville mobilisation
du foncier public également dans les
lois notres et maptam on y parle et on y
fait également référence aux politiques
du logement donc on le voit beaucoup de
de dispositions législatives et
réglementaires et des changements aussi
parce qu'à travers toutes ces
dispositions il y a eu un certain nombre
de changements législatifs et
réglementaires incessants donc on a
aussi à la lecture du projet de loi la
crainte d'un risque de
complexification de créer des
dispositifs qui pourrai être assimilé à
de véritables usines gaz en particulier
sur les politiques d'attribution dont
vous avez rappelé quelques quelques
mesures sous prétexte de plus de
transparence et de mixité sociale mais
jusqu'où va la mixité sociale parce
qu'encore une fois je pense que faire
habiter les pauvres chez les riches
c'est peut-être faisable mais faire
habiter les riches chez les pauvres je
crois que véritablement ça semble
particulièrement compliqué et puis aussi
le deuxième volet qui voit quand même de
nouveau des mesures pour le moins
extrêmement coercitive à l'égard des
élus et plus particulièrement à l'égard
des maires et donc et en donnant
toujours plus la main à l'état et la
main au préfet dont on le voit à certain
à travers un certain un nombre
d'articles où ce sont les préfets qui
véritablement prennent la main et se
substituent que ce soit en matière
d'attribution lorsqu'il n'y a pas les
pourcentages et pour donc faire les
attributions manquantes que ce soit en
matière de non réalisation des objectifs
SRU et des sanctions qui sont donc
prononcées à l'égard des maires donc
montrant là une certaine défiance à
l'égard des des élus et et des maires
alors pour rentrer plus dans le détail
donc vous avez parlé de l'attribution de
25 % de logement locatifs sociaux au
premier quartil des ménages les plus
pauvres hors quartier politique de la
ville alors si justement on narrive pas
à atteindre ce pourcentage ou si le
bailleur refuse de signer une convention
donc de intercommunale d'attribution le
préfet le préfet lui procédera aux
attributions manquantes sur l'ensemble
des contingents alors comment ces
dispositions vont-elles s'appliquer en
pratique ensuite le projet de loi
prévoit la suppression de la possibilité
de déléguer au maire des contingents
préfectoraux c'est-à-dire que le préfet
encore une fois aura le choix il aura le
choix ou de ou de supprimer cette
possibilité ou de la maintenir donc là
aussi quels critères seront retenus pour
décider ou non de la suppression de la
délégation qui peut être donné à des
maires d'attribuer sur des contingents
préfectoraux
sur la liste des publics prioritaires
vous y êtes revenu et vos propos me
rassurent quelque part parce que c'est
vrai que si on prend déjà les dallo plus
une liste des publics prioritaires qui
s'est quand même encore allongé que
reste-t-il pour des ménage vous avez
cité des jeunes vous avez cité des
personnes âgées avec des pensions
extrêmement faibles mais aussi des
familles de conditions modestes qui
elles finalement ne sont pas ou toutes
ces personnes considérées comme des
publics prioritaires et qui donc dans
les fils d'attente des demandes de
logements sociaux et bien voit passer
continuellement devant elle des publics
d'allau ou des publics prioritaires
alors que ces personnes-là ont aussi
besoin d'un logement social et là il y a
aussi une problématique sur un risque de
rupture d'équité sur les mesures
d'attribution en en défaveur des
communes il y a la suppression de la
possibilité pour la commune de créer une
commission
d'attribution donc ça c'est quand même
je pense que les maires seront quand
même alertés sur ce sujet il y a la voix
prépondérante qui est donnée au
président de leepci sous certaines
conditions dans les commissions
attribution ce qui veut dire que le
maire dans ces mêmes commissions
attribution n'a plus une voix
prépondérante sur au moins son
contingent de la commune il y a la mise
à contribution de son propre contingent
pour certaines attributions manquantes
je l'ai rappelé donc autant de mesures
qui risquent de décourager les maires y
compris les maires qui font des efforts
même s'ils n'atteignent pas les
objectifs et est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un
risque finalement que les maires
n'apportent pas leur garantiese dans des
conditions comme cellees-ci et on
pourrait les comprendre sur la loi su
j'ai auditionné le Conseil Général de
l'environnement et du développement
durable qui a fait un rapport très
intéressant sur l'application de la loi
SRU et qui s'est interrogé devant moi
sur le le réalisme des objectifs de
rattrapage pour les communes les plus
éloignées des objectif et il propose que
les préfets puissent ne pas prononcer la
carence lorsque la commune constate une
certaine progression c'est qu'on
prendrait plus en considération non pas
pour dédoiner des obligations des
objectifs de lo SRU mais on prendrait
plus en considération aussi des
objectifs de progression que des
objectifs fixe pourquoi ne pas avoir
inscrit une telle proposition qui vient
du conseil général de l'environnement et
du développement durable qui a fait un
rapport là-dessus dans le projet de loi
la suppression de la DSU pour les
communes carencé vous l'avez rappelé
donc j'allais vous demander comment
justifier une telle mesure mais vous
avez dit que là-dessus CIT l'Assemblée
nationale qui avait eu le le dernier mot
et puis il y a vous l'avez rappelé vous
n'êtes pas rentré dans les dans le
détail l'article 33 qui contient pas
moins de 12 ordonnances alors est-ce que
vos services travaillent déjà à la
rédaction de ces ordonnances et dans ces
ordonnances dans l'habilitation qui est
demandé par le gouvernement il y en a
quelques-unes qui sont quand même assez
sensibles qui touchent à l'avenir des
PLU et des Scotts dans le cadre du
contexte de la recomposition de la carte
intercommunale puisqu'il s'agit
d'adapter le régime des plu à la
situation qui est créée par la
recomposition de la carte intercommunale
et là il semble qu'il est qu même
antinomie entre d'une part s'il y a
fusion de deux EPCI dont l'un a déjà la
compétence plu et bien le nouvel EPCI
possède automatiquement la compétence
plu donc le mécanisme de fusion
priverait donc les les les justement les
communes du droit de vetto qui pourtant
avait été voté dans le cadre de
l'article 136 de la loi allure et qui
disait bien qu'il y avait avait un vetto
sur le transfert automatique de la
compétence plu au niveau intercommunal
donc là il y a antinomie entre les deux
il semble que vous évoquiez le fait
qu'il puisse y avoir une période
transitoire d'une durée de 5 ans mais
encore une fois c'est très flou le
gouvernement ne donne pas beaucoup
d'indications sur le mécanisme qui
pourrait être misise en place pour
justement réaliser cette conciliation et
comme ça touche quand même à des
domaines aussi sensibles que le droit
des sols vous augurez que faire tout ça
par habilitation demande d'habilitation
et par de danse ça peut nous
inquiéter ensuite sur des modifications
qui sont des dispositions qui avaient
été introduites pourtant par la loi
allure qui sont relative à la Commission
de contrôle des professionnels de
l'immobilier cette commission pour l'air
elle s'est jamais mise en place donc
elle a elle tarde à à voir le jour et
vous avez changé de position à
l'Assemblée nationale puisque vous avez
demandé à ce qu'il y ait une fusion
entre cette commission de contrôle des
professionnels de l'immobilier et le
Conseil national de la transaction et de
la gestion immobilière donc là aussi
j'aimerais avoir un petit peu plus de de
précision sur ces points-là sur le
surloyer donc vous l'avez assez
développé donc j'ai pas tellement de de
questions à vous poser en plus et puis
vous avez pas du tout parlé d'un
chapitre important qui concerne
l'accueil des gens du voyage dont il est
question à à la fois dans le chapitre
dans le titre 2 mais également dans le
titre
3 et donc à l'heure où on voit pas mal
de mèes qui sont aujourd'hui acccédés
par l'arrivée massive de gens du voyage
surtout à travers les les problématiques
des grands rassemblements et l'intrusion
de manière illicite sur des projets sur
des terrains privés au public donc
trouver l'équilibre qui est proposé à
travers un certain nombre de
dispositions qui a été introdu dans ce
projet de loi entre d'une part les gens
du voyage et la suppression de la
commune de
rattachement pour donner de nouveaux
droits à ces gens du voyage et en même
temps l'accélération des procédures
réprimant le stationnement illicite des
caravanes des gens du voyage donc voilà
l'essentiel des questions que je
souhaitais vous poser madame la ministre
bien merci Madame la rapporteur je donne
la parole à Françoise Gatel ensuite jeai
la parole à Yv rom puis philippe Dallier
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
madame la ministre de votre
représentation donc moi euh rapportant
sur les titres 1 et 3 je viendrai en
complément des excellentes questions
posé par ma collègue la première
observation que je fais parce que je
suis aussi vice-présidente de
l'Association des maires de France c'est
je je suis un peu comment dire
préoccupée par l'évolution des relations
de confiance que le projet de loi
instaure entre les collectivités locales
et l'État puisqu'on a une forme de
centralisation de la politique et de
l'action en matière de logement social
alors que le rôle des communes et non
seulement de loger mais il est surtout
de réaliser l'accompagnement social qui
est nécessaire pour que les gens
puissent vivre et puissent vivre
ensemble et que il me semble que là on a
une une relation de défiance qui
s'instaure un peu je reprendrai la
question très
importante de la dérogation
possible au transfert de la compétence
plu à
l'intercommunalité c'est une c'est une
vraie question aujourd'hui j'ai une
question très concrète qui a été posée
dans mon territoire je suis d les Villen
donc un territoire à la fois P et urbain
et un peu rural sur la nature du
logement social et le le contingent de
logement social qui nourrit une partie
de la DGF dans beaucoup de de de
communes il y a un vrai souhait de se
mobiliser sur l'accession sociale à la
propriété ça correspond à une réalité du
territoire et ça correspond à la demande
des des des attributaires potentiels or
euh les les actions menées en faveur des
des des acquisitions sociales
nécessitent des efforts financiers aussi
significatifs de la part des communes
mais n'entre pas dans le Cotat de
logements sociaux et pour nous c'est une
vraie question sachant qu'on a des
opérateurs des bailleurs sociaux qui
refusent d'aller dans certaines communes
et se concentrent dans une partie très
métropolitaine enfin autre question qui
a tras à l'air des gens du voyage donc
ma question n'est pas politiquement
incorrecte ni égoïste elle est très
franche aujourd'hui il y a et c'est très
bien une obligation fait aux communes de
5000 habitants c'était le seuil d'avoir
une are des gens du voyage une aire
d'accueil pour les gens du voyage sur
leur territoire dans mon département d'î
et Villain il y a un schéma
départemental les communes s'y sont
pliées tout tout tout va bien or je
constate aujourd'hui il y en a 41 j'ai
demandé au préfet de me donner les
statistique d'occupation des aires des
gens du voyage dans certaines parties du
département le taux d'occupation est de
5 % et en dehors de la métropole où on a
des taux d'occupation de de de 90 % il
ne ne dépasse pas le 42 ou le 50 % or
aujourd'hui il y a dans les territoires
rurauopér urbains des communes nouvelles
qui apparaissent ce qui font qu'on a une
augmentation de de la taille des
communes et sincèrement je m'interroge
sur la pertinence d'une non révision de
cette taille d'habitant sachant je
prends encore l'exemple de ma commune
autour de ma commune à 5 km il y a 6
aires d'accueil des gens du voyage et
qu'à un moment où les dotations de
l'État sont sont aussi en BGE je pense
qu'il est de du devoir des collectivités
d'avoir un schéma d'air d'accueil des
gens du voyage il faut pas le le
remettre en cause mais je pense qu'on
pourrait s'interroger sur sa pertinence
au niveau de ce cotage je vous
remercie bien merci madame le rapporteur
alors nous allons maintenant entendre
les intervenants des différents groupes
je vous rappelle que vous avez 2 minutes
d'une façon extrêmement surveillé ivrom
a la parole ensuite fier madame ministre
il y a eu certes des avancées à
l'Assemblée nationale sur l'objectif des
25 % des attributions hors quartier
politique de la ville au ménage le plus
défavorisé pour prendre en compte cette
réalité l'occupation sociale d'un
quartier comment cet objectif de 25 %
va-t-il pouvoir être ajusté si j'ai bien
compris c'est pas au contraire par une
défiance des élus mais une plus grande
responsabilisation des élus au niveau
des epciers comme quoi parfois les le
vocabulaire peut distinguer certaines
visions différentes de la pr d'un projet
de loi par contre le supplément de loyer
de solidarité est renforcé et le
dispositif de perte du droit au maintien
dans les lieux également alors ne
craignez-vous pas mais j'ai bien noté
les avancées que vous avez souligné que
ces mesures puissent avoir un effet
contreproductive dans la recherche de la
nécessaire mixité sociale enfin on peut
se féliciter également des ajustements
concernant la loi SRU ce n'a pas été
souligné mais des communes pourront
sortir du dispositif il s'agit des
communes situées en zone détendue ou
celle comprenant une part importante de
terrain inconstructible ou encore mal
desservi par les transports en commun et
cette notion me paraît tout à fait
essentielle ces ajustements sont
bienvenus et on peut se féliciter que le
gouvernement est été à l'écoute des élus
enfin dernière question puisque en
matière de construction et de mixité
sociale tout commence et tout se termine
par la maîtrise nécessaire du foncier
j'aimerais connaître votre position
quand à la couverture nationale entre
les établissements publics fonciers
locaux encore trop rares mais qui ont
fait grâce à à l'action des élus preuve
d'une très grande efficacité en libérant
du foncier pour promouvoir la
construction du logement et bien entendu
la place que vous souhaitez accord aux
établissements publics fonciers
régionaux plutôt sous contrôle des de
l'État même si les élus ils sont
largement associé bien mercirob la
parole est à Philippe daller ensuite à
François scartron merci monsieur le
président enfin en 2 minutes je sais pas
très bien ce que je vais pouvoir dire
euh j'espère que je sortirai de ce débat
pas seulement de de cette réunion mais
du débat que nous aurons en séance en
ayant les idées claires sur ce que c'est
que laamicité sociale et comment elle se
mesure quand vous êtes en plein milieu
de la scène Saint-Denis est-ce que les
critères qpv pas qpv 25 % pas 25 % ont
le même sens que agéré dans la Creuse je
ne suis pas certain et malheureusement
on continue alors moi sur le volet
attribution et un/4 des attributions au
quart des plus pauvres moi j'ai pas de
souci par contre ce que je sais c'est
que certaines villes sont auudessus des
25 % de logements sociaux et qu'elles
ont en revenu moyen par habitant le
double de ce qu'il y a dans ma commune
je précise les choses parce que ce débat
finit par être tellement caricatural
celui de l'article 55 de la lou que je
n'en peux plus je vous le dis tel que je
n'en peux plus je vais vous donner
l'exemple de ma commune il y a 21 ans
j'ai étél maire il y avait 6 % de
logements sociaux la ville avait été
gérée pendant 80 ans par le Parti
socialiste c'est comme ça aujourd'hui il
a 15 j'ai gagné 30 % de population 30 %
de population en 20 ans je suis arrivé à
15 % et on me dit tout d'un coup c'est
plus 15 c'est 25 et c'est en 9 ans
résultat ce que disait notre rapporteur
est tout à fait vrai pour les villes qui
étaient le plus éloigné de l'objectif ça
devient impossible je n'étais pas
éligible à la DSU j'y suis rentré à la
752e place je suis à la 570e je
progresse je vais peut-être bientôt me
trouver dans les 250 premières finira
peut-être comme ça c'est un objectif
qu'on peut effectivement chercher à
atteindre tout ça pour dire avec un peu
d'emportement que la mixité sociale ça
peut pas être regardé de la même manière
au milieu de la scène saint-ie ou
ailleurs en province or ce qui est
dramatique dans ce que vous êtes en
train de faire c'est que vous regardez
les choses de la même manière partout
alors heureusement à l'époque on nous
disait c'est 20 % pour tout le monde que
vous n'ayez pas de terrain que vous en
ayez c'est pareil on progresse
effectivement on va même jusqu'à
regarder un indicateur qui va dire si la
zone est tendue ou pas tendue il y avait
notre collègue le squarznack qui nous
avait expliqu effectivement dans la
Bretagne on lui demandait de construire
avec qu' avait de la vacance dans le
logement social mais ceci étant dit moi
j'aimerais etess et je termine là-dessus
monsieur le Président pourquoi est-ce
qu'on nerse pas la logique des choses
madame la ministre pourquoi est-ce que
on ne signe pas un contrat entre une
commune et l'État un contrat qui tienne
compte effectivement de la disponibilité
du foncier mais aussi des moyens des
collectivités locales parce que je vais
vous dire si j'ai pu assumer 30 % de
population en 20 ans j'avais de
l'autofinancement avec la baisse des
dotations il me reste quasiment plus
rien
avec les pénalités que vous faites
porter quand on sera en carence j'ai
jamais été en constat de carence depuis
2001 j'ai même fait le double je finirai
la période triénale en ayant rempli mes
objectifs en 2017 madame la ministre je
suis mort faudrait que je fasse 900
logements sociaux en plein milieu de la
SA saint en moins de 9 ans avec toute la
bonne volonté du monde je les ferai pas
et donc je serai en contat constate
carence vous me prendrez 5 % de mes
recettes de fonctionnement et vous ferez
sauter la DSU écoutez mes chers
collègues vous vous
pour les quelques maires parce qu'ils ne
sont que quelques-uns qui disent au
effort qu'il ne veulent rien faire et
pas de logement social vous en arrivez à
des dispositions qui sont ahurissantes
pour ceux qui sont plein de bonne
volonté et qui ont fait alors j'espère
que je vous convaincrai au moment du
débat mais je viendrai avec une autre
proposition qui est l'idée d'un contrat
état commune avec des moyens financiers
pour acheter les terrains pour
construire les équipement public parce
que sans ça on ne construit
pas merci mon cher collègue vous avez
dépassé simplement de quelques secondes
le temps de parole qui vous était
accordé je donne la parole à Françoise
Cartron et ensuite à Daniel
Dubois merci monsieur le Président alors
en 2 minutes moi je vais essayer aussi
de d'attirer de de remettre le sens
qu'il y a derrière derrière cette
volonté cette cette loi et cette
problématique de mixité sociale je vais
remettre le sens par rapport à à quelque
chose qui nous concerne tous c'est
l'école et son fonctionnement
aujourd'hui tous les constats montrent
que l'échec scolaire sur lequel tout le
monde se lamente est éminemment lié à
une non mixité sociale on continue à
déverser de l'argent supplémentaire dans
soi-disant ses Z dans ces établissements
très ségrégués et on s'aperçoit je suis
obligé de le dire que malgré l'argent
déversé le résultat n'est pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'on attend et pourquoi
il n'est pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on
attend parce que c'est la constitution
même de ces logements de de ces
établissements scolaires qui sont très
ségrégués qui font obstacle donc moi je
dis que il est absolument nécessaire
aujourd'hui lorsque vous avez des
établissements scolaires où 90 % des
enfants sont catégorie euh la plus
défavorisé allez-y dans ces
établissements allez entendre les
enfants allez VO quels sont leurs
référents quels sont leurs modèles et
vous comprendrez la difficulté de
l'école aujourd'hui dans ces
établissement donc je crois qu'il y a
urgence à rétablir de la mixcité sociale
et ce que l'on nous dit partout dans ces
quartiers là c'est que on ne peut pas
faire de mixité dans les établissements
tant qu'on aura pas de mixité dans les
logements parce que c'est étroitement
lié donc moi je pense que aujourd'hui il
y a ce problème à prendre à bras le
corps et à le prendre avec cet objectif
qui est de la cohésion sociale mais
aussi de la réussite de tous les enfants
où qu'ils habitent et quel que soit leur
lieu de naissance bien merci François
Cartron la parole est à dianelle Dubois
et ensuite à Éveline yonet merci
monsieur le
Président moi je voudrais tout
simplement je dirais intervenir sur des
actions un peu
praticopratique comment je dirais ça va
se passer de façon très opérationnelle
sur le terrain pour mettre en place
finalement ce principe de mixité dont
tout le monde en a plein la bouche je
dirais mais la réalité du
terrain les les directeurs d'organisme
HLM les élus sont confrontés à de vraies
réalités donc comment on fait alors moi
je voudrais vous poser une ou deux
questions sur le sujet tout d'abord vous
ne raisonnez pas en vous raisonnez en
flux et non pas en stock c'est-à-dire
que vous prenez pas du tout la réalité
de ce que sont les organismes HLM
aujourd'hui et pour le moins on aurait
pu prendre en compte les enquêtes
sociales qui ont été été faite pour
tenir compte de la réalité de certains
organismes HLM faute de quoi c'est les
organismes HLM qui vont devenir ghetto à
la place des quartiers donc cette
réalité là je pense que il faudra en
dire un mot ensuite dans l'article 20
madame la ministre vous modifiez
l'article 441 de nombreuses fois et
entre autres deviennent jeais publ
prioritair les personnes qui cumulent
des difficultés financières ça c'est une
réalité que connaissent tous les
organismes HLM et des difficultés
d'insertion sociale donc on sait que
cette problématique là est très
difficile à gérer par les organismes HLM
en particulier je dirais dans les
résidence collective et on sait aussi
que l'État assuma une partie des
responsabilités financières dans le
cadre de l'insertion sociale qu'en
est-il aujourd'hui à travers le Faita
que ce public devient prioritaire on
n'en dit rien du tout ensuite il est dit
également que les organismes HLM vont
être tenus par des engagements de mise
en œuvre de politique pour assumer cette
mixité alors moi j'aimerais que vous
nous précisiez très clairement quels
sont ces engagements est-ce que les
organismes HLM vont devoir faire l'école
est-ce qu'ils vont devoir faire la
police est-ce qu'ils vont devoir
remplacer les services publics qui ne
sont plus présents que vont devoir faire
les organismes HLM sur les qpv pour
faire en sorte que cette mixité jeis
soit mise en œuvre ensuite vous dites
que l'on va reloger les expulsbl j'ai
presque terminé monsieur le Président on
sait très bien sur le terrain attendez
c'est des réalités vécues au quotidien
moi je comprends je dirais qu'une
personne expulsable soit prioritaire
ceci étant dit si vous avez 90 % de
logement collectif et que vous gérez une
personne expulsable et que vous êtes
tenu de la reloger dans le collectif d'à
côté moi je sais pas comment vous faites
territorialement et la prise en compte
je dirais par les habitants dans le
quartier et ensuite vous nous dites il
faut rendre transparents les logements
vacants ouais les logements vacants on
le sait très bien quand ti un qpv à 90 %
les logements vacan sont dans le qpv si
vous voulez stigmatiser les quartiers
proposez cela et donc il y a des
incohérences opérationnelles et moi
j'aimerais que vous nous expliquiez
comment on fait merci beaucoup Daniel
Dubois la parole est à Eveline Yonnet
ensuite Alain Vassel merci monsieur le
Président alors moi j'ai écrit pour
éviter de perdre du temps donc je vais
rester dans mes deux minutes madame la
ministre cher Emmanuel merci d'être
d'avoir répondu à cette invitation non
seulement par ta présence à cette
audition mais aussi pour l'engagement de
longu dates sur les questions du
logement et de l'égalité entre les
territoire j'ai eu l'occasion de
d'accompagner madame la ministre lors de
plusieurs déplacements en Scine saint
NIS et je peux dire ici qu'elle connaî
bien ce territoire pour y avoir été à
plusieurs reprises ce qui se dégage de
égalité et citoyenneté c'est justement
cette philosophie d'écoute et de terrain
qui est à l'origine de ce texte les
questions d'accès au logement vous le
savez me tiennent en effet
particulièrement à cœur la semaine
dernière nous avons déposé avec mon
collègue Jean-Pierre suur une
proposition de loi relative à la lutte
contre les marchands de sommeil et
l'habitat indigne cette proposition a
été soutenue par Madame la Ministre
cette démarche nous paraît
complémentaire du volet logement social
du projet de loi égalité et citoyenneté
et nous nous tentons actuellement de
l'inscrire à l'ordre du jour en effet la
lutte contre l'habitat indigne et les
marchands de sommeil est indissociable
d'une augmentation sensible de le offre
d'hébergement transitoire c'est pourquoi
et de ce que j'ai entendu ici l'égalité
des territoires en parallèle du dépôt de
notre texte nous proposons d'intégrer
comme amendement dans le projet de loi
égalité et citoyenneté le rééquilibrage
territorial de l'effort d'hébergement
l'article l312 53 du code de l'action
sociale et des familles prévoit que le
plan local d'action pour le logement et
l'hébergement des personnes défavorisées
définit de manière territorialisée les
mesures destinées à répondre au besoins
en logement et en hébergement des des
personnes prises en charge par le
dispositif d'accueil d'hébergement et
d'accompagnement vers l'insertion et le
logement l'amendement que nous allons
déposer fixe des objectifs une place
minimum d'hébergement par tranche de
2000 habitants pour les communes membres
d'un établissement public de coopération
intercommunale dont la population est
supérieure à 50000 habitants ainsi que
pour les communes dont la population est
au moins égale à 3500 habitants et qui
sont compris dans une agglomération de
plus de 50000 habitants comprenant
eux-mêmes au Mo une commune de plus de
15000 habitants cet objectif est porté à
une place par tranche de 1000 habitants
dans les communes comprise dans une
agglomération de plus de 100000
habitants très concrètement il s'agit
ici d'appliquer la logique de la loi et
ses ru en matière d'équilibrage du
logement social sur tout le territoire à
la répartition des places d'hébergement
d'urgence d'une part mais surtout des
places d'hébergement transitoire madame
la ministre je me tiens à votre
disposition pour échanger bien merci
Éveline
Yonnet vous l'avez un peu dépassé mais
vous n'êtes pas la seule
madame la parole est donc à Alain Vassel
et ensuite à Yanic Vaugrenard merci
monsieur le Président hors temps de
parole est-ce qu'on peut tutoyer la
ministre et l'appeler par son prénom
c'est une nouvelle règle au sein de la
commission mon cher collègue je n'ai
absolument pas le pouvoir de
maîtriser le propos la part parle des
personnes qui interviennent dès lors que
ses propos sont corrects ils l'ont été
dès lors que la stricte politesse est
observée elle l'était alors si il y a
plus s'il y
a en tout cas des marques de sympathie
je ne peux évidemment pas toutes les
familiarités sont possibles moi j'ai
trois
questionention mais ce que vous avez dit
est pris sur V temps de parole mon cherè
parce que
allurés on efface je commence à 26 onace
TR questions qui vont être qui vont être
assez rapide euh je alors excusez-moi si
je peux être un peu décalé dans ma
question par rapport au exposé qui ont
été fait un je fais mienne les remarques
et questions tout à fait pertinentes
posées par nos deux rapporteurs et
j'adhère à ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure par mon collègue Daniel Dubois
donc ça m'évitera d'être redondant sur
ces points j'ai une question qui est le
résult d' vécu dans mon département
lorsque j'ai présidé pendant près de 40
ans une société d'HLM c'est lorsque
Madame Boutin était mis du logement elle
avait mis en place un dispositif qui
faisait qu'aujourd'hui on pouvait plus
construire du logement social que dans
le sud de mon département dans des dans
des donc dans des territoires qui
étaient à dominante urbaine par rapport
au territoire rural et on avait que les
miedes des financements qui restaient
pour construire en mie rurale dans le
nord du département est-ce que vous
arrivez par vos disposition à Perm
mettre à ce qu'on puisse construire du
logement social sur l'ensemble du
territoire d'un département et qu'il n'y
ait plus des secteurs privilégiés pour
mobiliser donc les financements ma
deuxième question en ce qui concerne
l'attribution des logements vous êtes en
train d'apporter de faire jouer un rôle
important et majeur aux intercommunalité
par le biais des conventions et au maire
mais la question que je pose c'est de
savoir quelle sera la sanction
financière pas au merde au président des
interc fais pas les commissions à hoc
quelle sera la sanction financière du
président de l'interco ou de la
commission adoc qui aura attribué un
logement à une famille qui sera
insolvable est-ce que l'interco
financera le loyer en en lieu et place
donc de la famille qui n'assure pas le
paiement c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
lorsque vous avez une expulsion qui est
refusé par le préfet c'est l'État qui
apporte la compensation financière donc
il faut responsabiliser celles et ceux
qui feront les attributions de logement
si les familles ne payent pas et ben il
faudra que les loyers viennent tomber
dans la CAE de l'organisme enfin je
termine par ma dernière remarque sur le
le fameux quotat de 20 ou 25 % est-ce
que le périmètre évolue est-ce qu'on
reste dans un périmètre communal ou
est-ce qu'on va évoluer vers un
périmètre
intercommunal bien merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à Yannick
Vaugrenard et ensuite à Francis delâre
oui merci monsieur le Président tout
d'abord une remarque un peu un peu
générale lorsqu'on a l'ambition de de
faciliter le logement social et la
mixité sociale euh je pense que
finalement il est pas inintéressant que
cette ambition soit empérée aussi par
une forme de réalisme de réalisme
territorial de de réalisme historique de
réalisme parce que le logement social
seul ne permettra pas la mixité sociale
il y faut également l'éducation et
François Cartron l'a fort bien évoqué
tout à l'heure il y faut également la
culture bref l'ensemble d'un
environnement qui qui ferait que la
mixité sociale est possible le logement
c'est très important mais il n'y suffit
pas donc voilà ce que je voulais
souligner et également je crois qu'il
peut pas y avoir de limite mais vous
l'avez dit Madame le Ministre pour
permettre à la loi d'allau qu'elle soit
complètement appliquée et s'il faut
dépasser les 25 % et bien nous
dépasserons les 25 % sans quoi et vous
l'avez dit avec juste raison nous
n'accepterions pas en quelque sorte la
mise en œuvre du 21e critère de
discrimination pour cause de précarité
sociale et donc il faut si c'est dépassé
c'est dépassé mais la priorité des
priorités ce sont me semble-t-il les
logements d'Alo et du coup si on si on
additionne l'ensemble des priorités que
vous avez défin tout à l'heure
pardonnez-moi mais j'ai l'impression que
trop de priorité risque de tuer la
priorité et donc effectivement je crois
que c'est plutôt les personnes en
situation délicate d'extrême pauvreté
qui doit être priorisé et et peut-être
aussi une forme de comment dire une
forme aussi de de mixité générationnelle
qui m'a paraît également importante et
et prise en compte sur les surloyers sur
les surloyers pardon je pense
qu'effectivement il faut qu'il y ait une
forme de prudence
euh les personnes peuvent du jour au
Lain ou avoir un cursus professionnel
qui fait que ils peuvent avoir un
surloyer mais appliquer du jour au
lendemain ou avec modération me semble
là aussi être une forme de sagesse et de
réalisme qui m' paraît vraiment vraiment
important enfin sur la suppression de la
DSU pour commune carencé là encore le
rôle du préfet représentant de l'État
doit être connu et reconnu et selon moi
s'impose à tous pour autant ce qui doit
s'imposer également au préfet c'est les
directives qui seront données par les
représentant de l'État au niveau central
et cette directive ça va pas être
uniquement une directive sous forme
pourcentage ou mathématique et c'est là
où l'ambition doit être tempérée par le
réalisme vous avez des communes qui font
manifestement des efforts qui parfois
sont bloqué au niveau du foncier et
objectivement ça peut être vrai qui
peuvent être bloqués également dans des
communes rurales parce que la demande
est insuffisante ou parce que les
offices HLM parce que c'est des petites
entités risquent de ne pas y aller et du
coup autant je suis d'accord pour que le
préfet applique avec une grande rigueur
dès lors que il y a manifestement de la
mauvaise volonté et on sait dans quel
secteur ça existe en particulier mais
autant il doit faire preuve de de
sagesse et et de réalisme dans
l'application et cela ça demande du
temps ça demande du contact ça demande
de l'échanges avec les collectivités
territoriales et avec les élus locaux
donc je pense qu'il faut tenir les
finalement les de bout du manche merci y
renard la paroletat franidolâre et
ensuite Christian Favier madame la
ministre mes chers collègues il est vrai
que l'État toujours eu du mal à vouloir
euh décentraliser collectivité
territoriale le logement hein c'est
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui mais quand on
voit l'échec où c'est nous qui dépensons
le plus et de très loin et quand on est
toujours en permanence en crise du
logement avec un coup supérieur à 50 %
de ce que ce qu'il est en Allemagne on
peut s'interroger sérieusement alors
deux contradictions Madame le Ministre
aujourd'hui nous recevons par dizaines
vingtaines des du préfet des décisions
des gens
expulsés
et ils arrivent donc les gens expulsés
dans nos mairies quen faisons-nous vous
ne pensez pas que ça serait quand même
un peu plus utile à un état social
d'essayer de trouver des solutions au
niveau d'avant la l'expulsion parce que
c'est ce que nous vivons c'est pas
euh plutôt que de faire des constats sur
la construction le constat social il est
pas glorieux
par volet entière on reçoit les
expulsions définitives des préfets en ce
moment et nous les avons sur les bras
les familles alors deuxème question la
mixité sociale est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est à 24 % qu'il a pas de mixité
sociale vous pensez pas que c'est à 50
60 80 % de logements sociaux sur des
sites où il y a un vrai problème de
mixité sociale c'est là où il est
essentiellement et personne ne trouve il
y a aucune solution concrète pour ce
genre de de site situation alors égalité
citoyenneté tout ceci c'est c'est c'est
c'est très très intéressant mais en
réalité c'est la reconcentration on
recentralise on a l'ambition de gérer
les cages d'escalier au niveau d'un
ministère et c'est le mal français alors
derre tout ça on a une campagne
publicitaire qui nous explique que les
Mair ne construisent pas assez sans
aucun sans sans aucun élément sérieux
qu'il démontre les ma construisent
pourquoi leur enlever cette
responsabilité en réalité nous savons
tous qu'il y a un vrai lobby dans ce
pays il y a lobby des promoteurs
parfaitement associé avec celui des
constructeurs de logements sociaux il
faut construire faut y aller
alors
naturellement le président de
l'agglomération qui a moins le sens de
la proximité AC les maires et l'hom
Douine pour l'instant voilà la alors
sachez simplement la ministre que tout
ça n'a rien à voir ni avec la
citoyenneté ni avec l'égalité c'est un
discours dont les finalités ne nous ne
nous échappent pas et je doute qu'on
arrive à un accord sur ce genre de de
proposition bien merci mon cher collègue
je donne la parole à Christian Favier
ensuite à Sophie prima oui merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
d'abord sur le fond moi je ne suis pas
évidemment convaincu que le l'absence de
mixité soit d'abord liée au mode
d'attribution des des logements mais
bien davantage évidemment aujourd'hui à
la faiblesse des revenus à la précarité
je dire aussi au coût du logement euh et
à l'insuffisance aussi du nombre de
logements sociaux qu'on constate en
particulier par exemple sur notre région
alors est-ce qu'il aurait mieux est-ce
qu'il valait pas mieux par exemple pour
favoriser cette mixité orienter
prioritairement par exemple les
personnes relevant du dalallot vers les
villes qui aujourd'hui ne respecte pas
la loi et ses rues et je mets pas dans
ces villes-là cell de notre collègue
d'allier où il y a des villes
effectivement qui étaient en dessous de
ces seuils mais qui font l'effort pour
essayer de de
remonter en proportion de logements
sociaux mais on a on a d'autres villes
qu' qu'on connaît bien qui refuse
systématiquement effectivement cette
construction est-ce qu'il faut pas
effectivement que les publics d'Alo
soient orientés d'abord sur ces sur ces
communes deuxème
aspect pour pour pour la construction
sur le surloyer le surloyer moi je ce
que j'ai pu constaté dans mon
département c'est que non seulement ça
n'a rien réglé du point de vue de la
réponse aux demandes de au aux demandes
de logements sociaux c'estàd que cette
demande de logements sociaux continue
d'augmenter de manière très fortement
malgré l'application du surloyer mais
que par ailleurs ça a ét un accélérateur
de la la géisation des quartiers parce
que effectivement les personnes de
conditions moyennes qui étaient qui
n'ont pas pu effectivement rester dans
le lement social on s'est trouvé
effectivement dans dans des
déséquilibres très très très fort dans
les quartiers donc je pense que
effectivement c'est pas la solution
enfin en région parisienne on va avoir
quelque chose de tout à fait particulier
avec la réalisation du Grand Paris
Express avec une explosion du nombre de
constructions qui vont être réalisées
autour des gares du Grand Paris 72 gares
nouvelles est-ce que j'ai déposé un
projet une proposition de loi pour
qu'autour de ces gares du Grand Paris il
y ait au moins 30 % de logements sociaux
qui soit prévu dans toute dans minimum
oui oui un minimum oui c'est un plancher
c'est pas un maximum 30 % dans toutes
les constructions nouvelles pourquoi
parce qu'on voit aussi quand on regarde
la situation
de de l'implantation de ces gares qui
vont bénéficier un réseau de transport
qui va bénéficier de de de financement
public et bien il y a des une très
grande disparité or le risque c'est que
la spéculation immobilière autour de ces
gares chasse au contraire les
populations les plus modestes au lieu de
faire en sorte que tous les salariés
puissent effectivement profiter aussi de
l'amélioration des transports auquels
ils aont d'ailleurs cont attribué par
par leurs impôts merci merci mon cher
collègue Christian Favier la parole est
à Sophie prima et enfin à Françoise
Laborde merci monsieur le Président très
rapidement pour dire que je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec les propos
qui ont été tenus par mon collègue
d'allier moi je voudrais simplement
porter la question sur vous voulez
attribuer 25 % des des ménages du
premier quartil dans les villes qui ne
sont pas en en en en priorité en
politique de la ville pardon en
politique de la ville moi j'ai une
question par rapport à celle qui
viennent d'en sortir euh je viens de
sortir de des politiques de la ville
j'ai 42 % de logements sociaux je suis
dans une ville des yvines où le niveau
moyen de de salaire est des plus faibles
de toute les Yvelines avec
montelaville je suis sortie je ne sais
pas pourquoi parce que nous avons
beaucoup de problèmes sociaux que nous
portons et je suis coincée entre deux
villes qui ont plus de 40 % de logements
sociaux et qui sont restés en quartier
prioritaire de la ville euh si bien que
c'est probablement chez moi pour des
raisons de continuité familiale pour des
raisons de proximité familial que vont
donc arriver ce premier quartil je ne
saurais pas faire je ne saurais pas le
supporter en terme d'accompagnement
social parce que là c'est véritablement
pour moi un accompagnement social très
fort qui est nécessaire avec de la
prévention des jeunes des adolescents de
la prévention à l'école des moyens
supplémentaires donnés dans les groupes
scolaires et cetera en politique
d'accompagnement scolaire également et
donc c'est une situation qui est une
situation très grave je parle de ma
ville qui est auberganville mais je
parle aussi d'une ville très compliquée
qui est celle d' queevill qui pour des
raisons extrêmement bizarres est sorti
de la politique de la ville extrêmement
on va dire dangereuse si je peux me
permettre cont tenu du contexte du
contexte de cette commune voilà donc
j'ai cette question par rapport au aux
villes et j'ai une autre question qui
concerne également une ville des Yveline
qui a beaucoup de logements sociaux très
au-delà de 30 % et qui maintenant se
voit par le préfet accorder des beaucoup
de réfugiés sur sa commune beaucoup de
dalallot que des dalallot sur le
contingent effectivement du préfet et
qui également voit arriver des contrats
entre des associations et des bailleurs
sociaux pour loger des réfugi dire qu'on
est en train aujourd'hui d'empiler
toutes les difficultés sur des communes
qui en plus sont en difficultés
financières je pense que là euh la le
rôle du préfet est vraiment très
important pour avoir du discernement
local et je vraiment je me battrai pour
que le rôle des mères soit reconnu
notamment dans les attributions car nous
connaissons nos caches d'escaliers une à
une et seul nous ça ça bien merci ma
cher collègue la parole est à Françoise
Laborde merci monsieur le Président bon
je vais être très bref parce que
beaucoup de choses ont été dit donc bien
sûr je participe au maximum aux
auditions des corapporteurs et donc j'ai
déjà aussi un certain nombre de réponse
ou d'idées d'amendement et donc
aujourd'hui vous allez aussi nous amener
des des réponses moi moi j'ai un petit
souci par rapport à tout ce qui a été
déjà dit sur les choix en effet entre le
le rural le péri urbain un certain
nombre de de lieux donc c'est vrai qu'en
ville les concentrations sont très
importantes et on peut appeler ça des
ghettos mais aussi on a le problème des
des logements que l'on éloigne aussi de
la ville et si on ne donne pas au
municipalité le moyen d'avoir des
transports et une aide on formera une
autre forme de ghetto les familles très
pauvres les monoparentales les familles
monoparentales avec enfant sans enfant
mais de toute façon sans emploi vont se
retrouver cachant ce que nous ne voulons
pas voir donc il va falloir quand même
trouver un équilibre entre les taux que
l'on applique en ville les taux que l'on
applique dans le péé urbain ou dans le
rural et je dirais qu'au niveau de
l'intergénérationnel c'est pareil si on
isole des personnes âgées qui n'ont
aucun moyen de se déplacer sa sera le
même problème et dans tout cela vous
rajouterez les bâtiments de France qui
dans les villages ne permettent pas que
les HLM soit près des villages
cachonsles derrière les fermes derrière
les bâtiments agricoles et ça ne gênera
personne bien merci Marie Noël lman
enfin demandé la parole je la lui
accorde oui je voulais demander à Madame
la Ministre de nous éclairer sur les
informations qui seront données d'après
la loi aux communautés de communes enfin
aux agloos euh pour éclairer justement
leur attribution parce que j'entends des
collègues dire on connaît euh quelle est
la réalité et cetera la réalité c'est
que nous avons besoin les collectivités
locales d'avoir unorté à connaissance de
la réalité du par exemple du nombre de
personnes qui bénéficient de l'APL par
résidence ce qui permet d'éclairer si
quand on attribue à une personne qui n'a
qui a laap en plus ont dit on va on va
accroître les problèmes sociaux dans
cette résidence alors même que dans
d'autres résidences le taux d'APL est
extrêmement faible et que c'est quand
même un des critères qui pourrait
éclairer euh la la diversité et c'est
pas parce qu'on connaît les gens qu'on
sait quel est exactement leur niveau de
revenu hein on est tous les uns et les
autres donc je voulais savoir à ma
connaissance les organismes HLM devront
porter à connaissance peut-être vous
pouvez nous expliquer quel mécanisme va
être mis en en en œuvre pour que ce soit
pas non plus la loterie des statistiques
sorties du vide et cetera euh la
deuxième chose que je voulais que vous
nous parliez c'est qu'effectivement pour
réussir l'amisté sociale il y a pas une
une seule solution c'est un long combat
d'une société qui doit revenir sur des
années depuis les années 60 avec à la
fois la poupérisation qui s'est accrue
depuis les années de crise et par
ailleurs la tradition d'urbanisme qui
avait été celui qui était dominant
rapatriille d'Algérie mutation urbaine
et cetera donc c'est un long chemin que
la France doit engager mais il doit il
doit y aller avec
détermination et c'est vrai que si la
situation sociale ne s'améliore pas
c'est quand même une course compliquée à
gagner donc je voudrais vous interroger
sur justement la question du niveau des
loyers parce que une des raisons pour
lequel une partie des catégories al il y
a il y a ceux qui veulent pas de pauvre
chez eux bon ça il faut qu'on sanctionne
mais il y a aussi des loyers il y a
aussi non mais je m'excuse non je j'en
connais pas mal hein mais il y a aussi
des loyers il y a aussi des loyers qui
ne sont pas accessib marinman termine
son intervention il y a des loyers dans
certains secteurs qui ne sont pas
accessibles à des populations modestes
donc au-delà des procédures que vous
proposez est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire comment l'État pourra accompagner
financièrement une requalification et
pas simplement au niveau
euh comment dire le total de des loyers
étant les mêmes parce que quand vous
avez déjà un parc assez cher euh vous
allez augmenter qui qui pour baisser les
autres donc quel outil pour accompagner
les baisses de loyer dans les secteurs
favorisés merci marnel lman madame la
ministre nous avons entendu 15
intervenants plus les deux rapporteurs
dans un temps qui finalement était
relativement limité grâce à l'autorité
malmenée du président bien madame la
ministre vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président je vous rappelle qu'il y a une
séance de questions dans 1 heure oui
j'espère de pas vous infliger une heure
de réponse mais
je vais essayer de d'apporter pas mal de
de de de retours sur vos questions en
sachant qu'il y a pas mal de questions
qui ne relèvent pas du tout du texte de
loi et je vais quand même y répondre
aussi parce qu' compris vous ouvrez sur
des débats plutôt budgétaires ou autres
mais je vais venir je voudrais
simplement parce qu'à vous entendre j'ai
cru peut-être mêtre mal
exprimé moi je ne dis pas que la mixité
sociale ne se fait que par le logement
je ne l'ai jamais pensé je dis qu'elle
se fait par le logement et par bien
d'autres choses et je crois notamment
que la mixité sociale ne se réalise que
si euh elle se joue aussi dans les
établissements scolaires dans les lieux
de consommation et dans les lieux
culturels enfin on est quelques-uns à
être franciliens ici à très bien
connaître ce que c'est que la
ségrégation territoriale en plus de la
pauvreté et chacun connaît ses
territoires et on sait bien que euh
faire de la mixité sociale c'est euh
c'est justement trouver des endroits où
on arrive à avoir euh des des une vie
euh de de de personnes qui ont sur des
revenus différents et des histoires
différentes la seconde chose c'est que
moi je ne pense pas que la mixité
sociale se résume à des questions de
pauvreté ou de
richesse je pense qu'aujourd'hui une des
questions qui explique d'ailleurs la
politique de la ville qui explique ça
c'est surtout la concentration de
l'extrême pauvreté et aussi la
concentration de l'extrême richesse on
peut quand même aussi se dire les choses
on parle beaucoup des getteau de pauvres
la réalité c'est que nos territoires
sont aussi fait de guetto de riche dans
lesquels on ne peut pas rentrer et
notamment parce que c'est pratiqué par
le prix du logement pas d'ailleursog
logement social c'est pratiqué par le
prix du logement privé et il faut il
faut le reconnaître et je pense que ce
texte de loi dit aussi cela voilà c'est
le fruit d'une histoire politique de
défis autes qui ont été qu' ont été
portés à un moment il fallait loger tout
le monde il fallait construire il
fallait moderniser notre pays mais on a
aussi on est aussi revenu là-dessus les
programmes de renouvellement urbain
c'est pas non plus uniquement par le
désir de telle ou telle politique c'est
que ça répond à des désordres urbains
réels et et d'ailleurs on les poursuit
on a comme même 200 nouveaux quartiers
en renouvellement urbain au niveau
national beaucoup aussi au niveau
régional et c'est long c'est très long
de défaire ce qui a été construit
pendant 30 ans c'est très long de le
défaire et en effet il faut de nombreux
mandats de nombreuses politiques amené
et voilà
faire faire le vivre ensemble ça
implique en effet de la durée de la
politique et aussi de l'investissement
et si je vous dis ça c'est que moi je
suis très modeste sur ce que je présente
devant vous je pense que ça permet
objectivement d'améliorer les questions
de mixité sociale mais c'est pas à à à
soi seul ce qui va permettre de le faire
de la même manière que derrière notre
débat et je vais venir après vos
questions très
précises faut qu'on fasse attention à ce
qu'on dit quand je parle des ménages qui
appartiennent au premier quartil du des
demandeur sur une EPCI puisque c'est ça
que dit le texte de loi dans ces gens-là
vous avez pas que des gens extrêmement
pauvres vous avez des gens qui vivent
tous les jours qui travaillent qui ont
des enfants mais qui ont des très
faibles revenus parce que le travail est
intermittent parce que qu'il est pas à
temps complet parce qu'il y a des
périodes de chômage et d'activité il
faut aussi être très clair il faut qu'on
regarde en face quels sont les revenus
de nos concitoyens et c'est bien pour et
nos concitoyens qui ont des problèmes de
logement ils sont nombreux alors dans
des zones très tendues ils concernent
beaucoup de nos concitoyens dans des
zones moins tendues il en concerne un
peu moins mais c'est vrai que quand on
est pauvre et qu'on est pas très mobile
et qu'on a pas un emploi permanent et à
temps complet on a beaucoup de mal à se
loger et à se loger correctement et donc
la la bataille du logement abordable
elle est absolument essentielle et donc
l'état évidemment la porte sur la
question du logement social et je vais
venir à nos questions mais il faut aussi
être très clair d'ailleurs on a aussi la
bataille du logement privé on a des
villes monsieur Dalier parlait de sa
ville et des villes avoisinantes on a
quand même des villes à côté de pavillon
sous-bois qui ont un niveau de
population surous le seu de pauvreté
énorme et la différence entre le parc
privé et le parc social est pas très pas
très différente sur les difficultés euh
sociales et c'est aussi pour ça qu'il y
a un tel engagement financier pour
produire du logement notamment privé qui
soit à coût abordable moi je vais vous
dire mon combat c'est pas simplement de
répondre au problèmes d'attractivité de
la France par rapport à d'autres pays
européens et et et euh des appartements
de standing la question c'est de loger
les Français et ben les Français ils ont
des revenus médians qui sont pas très
élevés et aujourd'hui la réalité c'est
que par manque de logement et par grande
difficultés on a beaucoup de territoires
où on a des concitoyens qui dépensent
jusqu'à 50 % de leur revenus pour se
loger et souvent se loger mal par
ailleurs donc et je je le dis devant
vous parce que je je pense qu'il faut
pas se faire de faux procès on a la
question des gens qui sont absolument
sans revenus et relèvent des politiques
d'hébergement et euh les villes
évidemment contribuent beaucoup euh à
cette politique et on a la question des
gens qui sont modestes et le sujet de
l'attribution des logements au ménag du
premier quartier ça correspond notamment
à des des familles modestes et qui
objectivement aujourd'hui ne rentrent
pas dans le logement social comme elle
devrait y rentrer c'est dur à
reconnaître et c'est vrai que on n'a pas
encore me semble-t-il l'ensemble des des
des des informations euh euh décliné
territorialement qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui de regarder la réalité
totalement mais on va justement se les
donner alors à partir de là pour
répondre à différents différents
question
euh la première chose pour répondre au
aux remarques de Dominique estrzi euh je
pense qu' il faut euh je je enfin on
peut avoir des désaccords évidemment
mais euh la question n'est pas dans le
texte de loi de de sanctionner les
maires ou de les prendre à mal je pense
qu'il y a deux débats différents d'une
part le texte de loi qui a été présenté
au départ par le gouvernement et celui
qui en sort a montré que j'ai cherché
avec les parlementaires à impliquer
totalement les territoires et
aujourd'hui en matière de logement le
territoire c'est essentiellement le PCI
c'est la suite de différentes lois c'est
c'est aujourd'hui le sens du mouvement
et ça ne veut pas dire que ce n'est pas
le maire qui derrière accorde son permis
de construire et joue y compris son rôle
de garantie mais par contre en effet et
moi je l'assume parfaitement en matière
de commune carencé lié au logement
social quand il n'y a pas de volonté de
faire ça concerne peu de communes mais
ça en concerne quelques-unes en effet
nous assumons le fait que pour ces
commune là le préfet prendra l'entièreté
des pouvoirs que jusque là était dévolué
au maire ça concernera peut-être que 25
ou 30 communes j'espère le moins
possible pour tout vous dire on voit
quand même que y compris ce qui a été
renforcé dans l'application de la loi
SRU en 2013 avec la possibilité de
prendre les permis de construire la la
le renforcement de l'action sur les
signatures de contrat de mixité sociale
ont porté leur fruit on a beaucoup de
communes qui se sont engagé dans la voie
du respect de la loi SRU après il est
certain qu'il y a des communes qui
n'ayant rien fait pendant 15 ans
aujourd'hui beaucoup de mal après il y a
un autre sujet qui est celle posée par
Monsieur Dalier qui sont des communes
qui ont des volumes de population
importantes et sur lesquelles les
volumes de construction sont extrêmement
importants mais en effet il y a il y a
aussi il faut être très clair et je le
vois tous les jours et je l'ai redit à
l'Assemblée j'ai été mise en cause par
une députée maire sur une commune qui
est toujours à cette % de logements
sociaux après 15 ans d'application de la
loi qui en même temps a délivré ces 10
dernières années 1000 permis de
construire donc ne me dites pas qu'il
était pas possible de construire il est
en tout cas pas possible de construire
du logement social et c'est pour ça que
très clairement dans la dans les
disposition de la loi SRU on a voulu
répondre à plusieurs sujets renforcer
les pouvoirs de l'État là où la loi
n'est pas du tout appliquée notamment
parce que vous parlementairire vous nous
reprochez notre manque de fermeté et de
sanction quand ce n'est pas appliqué
prendre en compte compte des discussions
que nous avons avec les élus locaux sur
des communes par exemple en zone
détendue qui objectivement aujourd'hui
ont des obligations su mais il n'y a pas
de demande de de il n'y a pas de demande
de logement je sais plus si c'est ici
l'assemblée qu'on avait parlé de l'aglo
de Saint-Étienne et du département de
Saint-Étienne il y a une forte vacance
de logement des communes qui doivent
respecter la loi SRU mais aujourd'hui
notre difficulté c'est toute façon on a
une vacance sur l'ensemble du
département et donc et en plus c'est des
communes d'ailleurs qui commencent à
construire qui ne sont pas ement au
respect de la loi SRU mais qui qui
construisent et donc c'est pour cette
raison notamment que nous avons préféré
mettre en place la question du taux de
pression pour justement regarder
l'adéquation entre les besoins de
logements sociaux et besoins de et la
demande et aussi regarder ces communes
qui sont pas du tout DESS servies par
des transports en commun on a aussi le
cas de ces communes dans le cadre de la
nouvelle nouvelle cadre de
l'intercommunalités ces communes qui
sont tout au bout des
intercommunalités prenons des exemples
comme des communes prenons la Glot de
Valence euh on a j'ai oublié le nombre
de communes je m'en excuse mais Valence
et puis autour des toutes petites
communes qui beaucoup sont soumis à la
lois SRU mais y compris parfois des
communes qui sont elles-mêmes la réunion
de d'anciennes communes avec des
territoires totalement épars et on sait
bien que là la question c'est pas tant
le logement social au bout de
l'agglomération c'est peut-être
justement des programmes bien situés là
où il y a des transports c'est ce que
vous permet la loi aujourd'hui et en
plus en responsabilisant les élus parce
que moi je pense que c'est assez
étonnant que ça soit le ou la ministre
du Logement qui à la fin prennent toute
seulle la décision de rentrer de faire
sortir des communes nous avons souhaité
instaurer le fait qu'il y ait une
délibération de le PCI cela obligera les
EPCI à avoir un débat sur le sujet que
les communes qui vraiment pensent
qu'elles sont légitimes à sortir de la
loi SRU puisse le présenter devant le
devant leur intercommunal il y a un
débat politique il y a une décision et
le débat permet d'aller au bout et je
crois que c'est justement ça aujourd'hui
qui est porté dans ce texte de loi c'est
de répondre à ces questions très
précises mais c'est vrai aussi et je
l'assume que là où par contre il ne se
passe rien je pense qu'au bout de 15 ans
d'application de la loi il faut
maintenant prendre en compte la réalité
et donc que l'État soit dans l'ensemble
de son de son rôle autre sujet c'est les
contingents préfectoraux
alors il avait été rendu possible que
les préfets délèguent leurs
contingents à des communes alors déjà
pour vous dire les choses ce n'est pas
du tout la majorité des cas ça s'exerce
dans quelques départements et quelques
régions et il y a beaucoup d'endroits où
en fait les communes pensent qu'elles
ont la délégation du contingent mais en
fait non elles ont un travail de
célaboration avec le préfet et en fait
elle décid ensemble mais les délégations
en tant que tell c'est celle qui relève
de convention avec des des des
désaccords oui en effet nous proposons
la suppression de ces délégations du
contingent après un avis du comité
régional de l'habitat et de
l'hébergement parce que dans l'ensemble
des chiffres que nous avons récupéré sur
les taux de relogement des publics
prioritaires des dallo qui est je le
rappelle de la l'obligation des de
l'État nous nous rendons compte que là
où le contingent est délégué nous sommes
pas du tout dans des pourcentages
acceptables et qu'il ne suffit pas comme
ça a été fait par le passé que les
préfets concernés soient convoqués par
les ministres concernés pour que même
rappell au maires leurs objectifs pour
que ça change et donc en effet nous nous
reprenons les contingents préfectoraux
après discussion devant les comités
régionals de l'habitat ça permettra en
plus d'avoir devant ces comités
régionaux la transparence sur les taux
de relogement sur ces contingents et il
y aura un avis qui sera pris par par ces
ces comités et je vais vous dire
pourquoi est-ce que nous avons lu mettre
fin à cette à cette à cette délégation
de contingent c'est que en même temps on
me dit qu'il faut pas les annuler mais
en même temps on me somme de reloger les
publics prioritaires et dalallot il y a
un moment il faut être clair la loi qui
a instauré le DALO a demandé à l'état de
reloger sur son contingent les publics
reconnus prioritaires et bénéficiairees
du dalallot et y compris je vous je vous
rappelle que nous payons des amendes
chaque année des astreintes très fortes
c'est me semble-t-il 45 millions pour
l'année dernière donc ce n'est pas une
petite
responsabilité que j'ai et donc oui en
effet le contingent préfectoral doit
être utilisé dans toute dans toute dans
toute sa dimension là-dessus mais et
c'est notamment le cas pour les
quartiers en politique de la ville parce
que c'est là où il peut y avoir du
frottement aujourd'hui ce que nous
mettons en place avec justement ce
travail au sein des conférences
intercommunale et y compris la
commission de désignation c'est que nous
asterons aussi le fait que il y ait un
dialogue entre le préfet et les communes
concernées notamment sur les qpv parce
qu'en effet se pose la question
aujourd'hui de répondre à nos
obligations sur les publics prioritaires
vous direz les choses très franchement
j'ai refusé tout élargissement de la
définition du public prioritaire seule
une a été admise qui concernait les les
personnes qui sortent de centre de
rééducation thérapeutique c'est très peu
de personnes mais on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait un blocage très fort sur
ces personneslà mais tout le reste nous
avons pas du tout changé la liste telle
qu'elle était écrite dans la loi dans la
loi qui qui est
là ensuite sur les histoires de
commission d'attribution en effet la
voix prépondérante est donnée au
président de le PCI puisque c'est
aujourd'hui au niveau de leepci que se
passent les choses et donc le maire n'a
plus sa voix prépondérante qu'il avait
qu'il avait jusque-l sur
sur la question des
ordonnances alors il faudrait que je
reprenne ma liste parce qu'il y en a un
certain nombre il y a des ordonnances
extrêmement techniques comme par exemple
la transposition d'une directive sur les
ascenseurs donc certaines très technique
il y en a une qui en effet nous aussi
nous la jugeons très importante qui est
celle concernant la la la fusion la
nouvelle carte d'intercommunalité
l'histoire des plui qui en fait nous ne
souhaitions pas au départ par intervenir
mais en fait les nouveaux calendriers
sur sur
les sur les plui nous a obligé
évidemment à avoir des des des
dispositions
transitoires sur cette question là parce
qu'on a en fait des des difficultés qui
peuvent arriver alors d'une part
l'ordonnance aujourd'hui n'est pas
écrite mais je pense que quand nous
aurons le le débat ensemble à la rentrée
nous pourrons évidemment détailler plus
fortement cette questionl vous dire
ensite qu'il s'agit pas de récréer la
loi allure là où il y avait des
minorités elle
reste il s'agit pas de transformer
l'esprit simplement on a deux questions
là où les plui existaient déjà on ne va
pas défaire ce qui a été construit sinon
ça voudrait dire que le travail est fait
donc ça on le maintient pour le
territoire qui est déjà doté d'un pli et
s'il fusionne avec un territoire qui n
avait pas un bah il faudra que l'autre
commence à y travailler mais on va pas
défaire ce qui a été fait et adopté
sinon il y aurait une incompréhension
totale donc c'est ça qu'on prévoit dans
expposition transitoire le deuxième
sujet c'est pour les très grandes
intercommunalités je pense notamment à
celle du Pays-Basque avec euh je sais
plus combien de communes mais c'est plus
de 150 je me voilà donc là euh on va
permettre qu'il y ait des plui enfin qui
a en fait un partage au sein de le PCI
parce qu'objectivement avec une telle
taille d'intercommunalité d'une part on
veut pas défaire le travail d'Urban
d'urbanistme enfin de travail
réglementaire qui a été fait et en plus
ne pas casser la dynamique donc notre
objectif est juste de permettre ces
périodes transitoires de ne pas déformer
évidemment euh tel que ça a été pensé
par le passé mais aussi de répondre au
aux soucis qui nous ont été remontés par
les associations d'élus qui nous
demandent une disposition transitoire en
sachant je vous le dis franchement qu'il
faut que ça ça dépend aussi du
calendrier d'application de la loi
puisque il faut absolument que ces
disposition soit disponible pour le 1er
janvier si je ne dis pas si je ne dis
pas de bêtises autre sujet c'est euh
donc dans les ordonnances c'est la
fusion de la Commission nationale de la
transaction et de la gestion immobilière
avec la commission de contrôle
euh c'est un projet que je porte avec
les professionnel euh je il s'agit pas
d'un changement de pied du ministère sur
cette question euh ça a été un un grand
débat vous le savez dans la loi àure une
évolution très forte concernant les
professions immobilières le code de
déontologie qui a été mis en place les
formations obligatoires la carte
professionnelle et cetera et cetera la
commission de contrôle n'était toujours
pas là et il a été décidé àprèsble de
discussion avec les professionnels
d'avoir donc de fusionner ces deux
organes en gardant en gardant la
l'organisation telle qu'elle est au sein
de la Commission nationale de la
transaction de la gestion immobilière
c'est-à-dire que l'on garde la
représentation des professionnels et des
consommateurs puisqueaujourd'hui au sein
de de la
cntgi il y a ces deux représentations
ces représentation importantes et nous
les sollicitons aujourd'hui pour
connaître des décrets les réécrire
débloquer qui est des sujets que le
législateur nous a posé il y a des
missions aujourd'hui sur la par exemple
la révolution numérique au sein des
professions immobilière mais donc nous
nous garderons la composition enfin
l'équilibre de la composition dans cette
nouvelle organisation parce qu'il faut
absolument et les professionnels le
souhaitent qu' gardent le ils veulent
garder le contact et le dialogue qui est
parfois vif et parfois doux avec les
associations de de consomateurs euh
alors euh autre chose parce que j'ai
entendu des remarques sur la Une une
volonté de centraliser la politique du
logement moi au contraire je j'ai
l'impression de porter un texte qui
continue d'aller dans le fil des textes
précédents qui est de donner au
territoire les moyens de mettre en œuvre
leur politique et y compris sur
l'attribution de logements sociaux
plutôt que d'avoir un
principe imposé par l'État 25 % et de
dire vous faites comme ça et puis c'est
tout nous disons 25 % mais vous pouvez
avoir une modulation de ce taux après
une discussion et un accord entre la
conférence intercommunale et l'État et
notamment pour prendre en compte la
situation locale c'est ça le sujet et
notamment pour prendre en compte parce
qu'en effet la situation n'est pas la
même dans certains départements très
précarisés et papérisés et de d'autres
territoires qui le sont moins et donc
avec des obligations différentes et puis
voilà il y a des zones très tendues avec
des obligations de relogement très
fortes des zones qui le sont beaucoup
moins il y a des besoins de relogement
qui sont différ on a aussi parfois des
endroits où on voit notamment et ça a
été dit tout à l'heure des besoins en
relogement par exemple de public qui
partent à la retraite qui est quelque
chose qu'on voyait moins avant dans le
logement social qu'on voit plus
aujourd'hui mais c'est pas le cas sur
tout le territoire on a aussi des
endroits on a du logement social vacant
ou du logement vacant tout court ce qui
n'est pas le cas sur l'ensemble de
territoire et c'est pour ça que nous
voulons mettre en œuvre cette politique
en lien avec les conférences
intercommunales dans des accords entre
le préfet et la la conférence
intercommunale et je pense que c'est
aussi un moyen justement de poser un
partenariat
très très important vous dire ensuite
que sur la question de qu'est-ce qu'un
logement social et notamment des
décomptes de ce qu' est un logement
social pour la loi
SRU moi je le redis par que je crois que
j'avais été interrogé par certains
d'entre vous sur le sujet notre volonté
n'est pas d'ouvrir le décompte SRU
notamment à l'accession sociale à la
propriété tout simplement parce que si
le PSLA loge des personnes qui sont
éligibles au logement social ça ne donne
pas plus de capacité ni à la commune ni
à l'état d'avoir un
contingent et je voudrais redire les
choses il y a 70 % des Français qui sont
éligibles au logement social quand il y
a de la construction privée vous
demandez pas à ce que ça rentre dans le
contingent SRU même si reloge des
personnes qui sont dans les niveau du
logement social le PSLA c'est un modèle
de d'accès à la propriété extrêmement
intéressant aujourd'hui parce qu'il
sécurisent des ménages modestes ou qu'
on des peurs de fragilité de revenus
mais ça reste de de l'accession à la
propriété ce n'est pas du logement
locatif et c'est pour ça que notre
volonté n'est pas de modifier l'esprit
de la loi su qui est le décompte des
logements locatifs sur lesquels il y a
en effet un accès un accès du contingent
pour les communes les bailleurs sociaux
et pour les et pour pardon l'État sur
les gens du voyage moi je voudrais
redire les choses ici tes que je les
avais dites lors d'une question je crois
orale un deos de de votre de vos
collègues c'est que je pense qu'en effet
et c'est le sens des dispositions qui
sont insérés dans ce texte de loi il
faut absolument avoir un équilibre entre
la fin des discriminations liées au
statut des gens du voyage et
l'application très claire d'une part la
construction des aires d'accueil ou des
aires de de passage et des
obligation de respecter la loi notamment
sur les occupations illégales là-dessus
c'est très clair et y compris dans les
dispositions qui sont insérées dans le
texte on renforce notamment les pouvoirs
de police sur cette questionl et on
garde évidemment cependant ce sont les
dispositions qui sont issues de la
proposition de loi de Dominique rimbour
et il y a très clairement la volonté
d'améliorer le statut des gens du voyage
mais aussi de renforcer très clairement
les pouvoirs de police notamment contre
les les les implantations illégales et
vous l'avez dit Madame tout à l'heure en
effet il y a des départ qui ont
totalement rempli leurs obligations euh
d'autres qui aujourd'hui sont dans
difficultés parce que notamment elles ne
disposent pas des aires de grand passage
qu'elles doivent construire et on voit
des difficultés de fait qui se reportent
sur les petites communes très clairement
où là où il y a des terrains disponibles
et après on a des taux d'occupation qui
sont en effet très différents en
fonction des territoires qui sont très
liés aussi à la mobilité la mobilité de
ces personnes et qui d'ailleurs par
ailleurs sont pas toujours les mêmes
taux d'occupation d'une année sur
l'autre donc euh mais je pense qu'on
pourra revenir sur cette question-là
évidemment si euh si vous le souhaitez
euh euh plus tard j'ai entendu votre
questionnement sur la pertinence de
réviser les dispositions sur les aires
d'accueil euh c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on est encore beaucoup dans la la la la
bataille pour que l'ensemble des
territoires se dotte de leurs schémas
départementaux des aires d'accueil je
crois qu'aujourd'hui ce qui fait le plus
grand manque c'est notamment les aires
de grand passage et c'est à à ces
moments-là qu'on a des difficultés euh
importantes euh euh sur euh euh il y a
une question sur les établissements
publics fonciers euh donc aujourd'hui
nous avons des établissements publics
fonciers locaux et des établissements
publics fonciers d'État euh à la suite
de la révision de la nouvelle euh pardon
répartition régionale enfin la création
des 13 grandes régions j'ai demandé à
l'ensemble des des territoires qui
aujourd'hui ont des ont des soit n'ont
pas d'établissements publics fonciers
soit ont plusieurs établissements
publics fonciers d'État ou locaux j'ai
demandé à ces préfets de région de nous
faire un diagnostic de la situation et
de voir comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
rationaliser euh l'action des uns et des
autres ça peut passer dans certains
territoires par une fusion j'ai bien dit
cela peut passer j'ai pas dit que
c'était obligatoirement cela il y a
d'autres endroits où il y a une
pertinence y compris historique à garder
des éabissements publics fonciers à un
endroit locaux pardon et à d'autres
d'états pu on a un dernier sujet c'est
qu'on des territoires qui n'ont rien du
tout et moi ma volonté c'est de donner à
l'ensemble des territoire un outil après
les communes s'en saisissent ou pas mais
ça c'est une autre histoire mais il me
semble très important aujourd'hui de
doter l'ensemble des territoires de ces
outilsl parce qu'on a en effet des
problèmes de restructuration foncière
des problèmes d'installation d'activités
économique ou de logement il y a pas que
la question du logement he d'ailleurs
dans le portage foncier on a beaucoup de
situations liées à des pollutions de
terrain notamment dans des zones qui ont
été industrielles par le passé et sans
un portage foncier au long cours on
n'arrivera pas à dépolluer ces sites et
à les construire et il me semble
aujourd'hui qu'il faut que l'on n donne
à l'ensemble des territoires ces ces ces
outils là donc là on a demandé un
diagnostic je pense qu'on aura les
retour plutôt à la rentrée puis après
moi je vais rentrer dans une discussion
locale avec y compris les régions et
l'ensemble des des collectivités qui
sont concernées pour qu'on trouve chaque
fois la bonne décision ça pose aussi
parfois des questions vous le savez
alors c'est c'est pas pas dans le texte
de loi là mais aussi des problèmes de
harmonisation des TSE puisque il y a
parfois des différence très forte et
dans la loi de finance on sera
certainement amené à demander que vous
nous permettiez de fractionner c'était
se pour pouvoir pour l'instant faire
coexister plusieurs plusieurs sujets sur
le foncier il est rajouté dans le texte
de loi d'avoir dans les PLH un volet
foncier qui est notamment une demande
qui a été portée par pas mal d'élus
parce queil souhait que l'on puisse à
l'occasion des PLH aussi commencer à
identifier le la territorialisation je
ainsi des logements qui seront
construits qui seront construits
à à venis
euh une question m'a été posée sur
lesexpulsions par il se trouve qu'après
les questions au Gouvernement j'animerai
un comité de pilotage justement sur les
expulsions puisque a été lancé il y a
plusieurs mois un plan national de lutte
contre les expulsions locatives
aujourd'hui les expulsions locatives
c'est 11000
expulsions exécuté pour à peu près 1200
dossiers au départ et et là-dessus je
pense qu'il y a il faut dire les choses
assez clairement on a d'une part euh
encore malgré un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont été préconisées et c'est
pour ça que je fais un comité de
pilotage aujourd'hui notamment euh une
politique départementale de lutte contre
les expulsions avec des référents
notamment euh euh sur ces sujets-là
notamment en terme d'information on voit
encore trop de dossiers où en fait on
intervient au moment où il est
absolument trop tard c'est-à-dire qu'on
ne prend pas euh la question de de la
personne en difficulté on l'AP prend
qu'au moment où l'expulsion est déjà
demandée voir va été prononcé alors euh
alors que euh il y a des sujets
d'impayer récurrents et pour vous dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont on a
moitié moitié d'expulsion demandé
logement social logement privé c'est à
peu près moitié moitié aujourd'hui euh
donc la question en effet des
préventions des expulsions est très
importante notamment sur les questions
d'un payé qui est le sujet qui est le le
plus important dans les causes des
expulsions des explulions aujourd'hui
mais pas que on a aussi des questions
qui sont liées à d'autres à d'autres
sujets euh et euh on voit quand même que
avec par rapport au nombre d'expulsions
demandé le taux je vous ai dit en 2014
dans mon souvenir de 11000 expulsions
effectivement prononcé des euh euh un
travail qui est fait quand même
énormément pour justement d'une part
éviter les expulsions mais aussi
résoudre les troubles et notamment la
question de l'impayé et je pense qu'il
faut être très clair aujourd'hui sur ces
deux questions en sachant par ailleurs
que les expulsions c'est bénéfique pour
personne hein c'est l'État qui prend en
charge ensuite au titre de ces
politiques d'hébergement euh très
clairement euh et donc on a aussi et
c'est pour ça que la question de la
prévention deexulsion notamment des
impayés est extrêmement importante et en
même temps d'être aussi très clair sur
les sujet
d'occupation qui qui dépasse le le la la
bonne occupation d'un logement et qui
peuvent justifier évidemment évidemment
des expulsions mais je tiens à le redire
hein la question des expulsions qui est
certes une question euh euh importante
aujourd'hui c'est pas ça qui fait
l'essentiel de notre public prioritaire
nos publics prioritaires sont
essentiellement euh des gens qui habit
en habitat insalubre ou ou indigne il y
a beaucoup de questions en effet de
familles qui ont des situations de
précarité très fortes et puis on a des
personnes handicapées qui n'
n'obtiennent pas l'adaptation de leur
logement parce que les travaux
n'interviennent pas malgré des crédits
qui sont là et qui sont réellement là et
puis euh évidemment des sujets aussi
importants que violence conjugale euh
séparation avec parfois des situations
extrêmement extrêmement difficiles euh
et et évidemment et puis aussi des des
questions parfois de de de cumul hein de
ces difficultés au même moment
euh m'a été posé à deux reprises des
questions sur le financement du logement
social qui est une autre question et qui
sera pas évidemment le temp texte de loi
mais notamment sur la capacité à ce que
les aides à la pierre aillent aussi au
territoire détendus et euh au
territoires ruraux qui est un débat que
nous avons déjà eu à plusieurs reprises
moi je partage votre souci je pense
aussi que ça fait partie des discussions
que nous aurons au sein du Fond national
des a à la pierre qui donc vient d'être
créé qui sera donc le lieu de discussion
des répartitions régionales des AES à la
pierre et au-delà de ça de comment
est-ce que l'on essaie que les a à la
pierre n'aillent pas que au métropole si
je veux à peu près exprimer ce que ce
que vous dites euh il est vrai aussi que
certains opérateurs sociaux ont du mal à
aller dans des des territoires où on
leur demande de construire peu de
logement pourtant il y en a d'autres qui
le font et euh et je je pense que je
réinsisterai làdessus au prochain
congrès HLM mais euh bon alors je dis
dans marine noëinman mais malgré tout la
Fédération des copes HLM a quand même
répondu à pas mal de territoir détendu
sur des petites opérations on a des
opérateurs notamment qui commencent à
être plus mobilisés par le collectivité
en leur disant écoutez la métropole
c'est bien mais il faut absolument
construire sur l'ensemble des
territoires et il est vrai que nous
devons continuer les uns et les autres
euh cette demande très claire aux
opérateurs de faire du logement social y
compris dans des territoires qui sont
pas les plus tendus je rappelle par
ailleurs que l'intermédiation
locative l'intermédiation locative elle
permet de d'avoir du logement social
dans des territoire détendu avec des
reprises de logements qui sont
réhabilités on a aujourd'hui des des
Programm d'intermédiation locative
notamment parlé par un des opérateurs
Solia qui un des plus grands opérateurs
sur le sujet qui reprennent par exemple
des logements municipaux euh qui et donc
l'intermédiation locative permet très
clairement de répondre à cette question
là et nous allons d'ailleurs euh
proposer de la développer notamment dans
territoire détendu et puis enfin il est
vrai que on a aujourd'hui pas mal de
communes je dirais rurales mais pas non
plus des petites communes mais qui
cherchent des moyens notamment d'avoir
des actions un peu plus mutualisées pour
essayer de construire ici ou là deux
trois cinq logements et c'est vrai que
se pose beaucoup la question aujourd'hui
de logements anciennement municipaux ou
en tout cas de bâtis qui qui relèv de la
de la ville qui pourrait être des futurs
lieux d'accueil de logement social dans
ces communes et c'est un actuellement
nous réfléchissons à donner les moyens
d'une expérimentation sur ce territoire
là euh pour répondre à une demande parce
que malgré tout ça représente des
logements infinés euh il n'est pas prévu
pour l'instant de sanction financière en
cas de non respect par les EPCI des
principes des attributions mais euh si
vous souhaitez mettre des sanctions je
vous laisse en discuter lors du texte de
loi euh sur la suppression de la DSU
j'ai pas été au bout de mon explication
tout à l'heure donc ça a été un débat
important donc suppression de la DSU
pour les communes carencé alors entre la
commission spéciale et le débat en
séance plinière les députés ont quand
même trouvé que même avait été avit eu
un peu la main lourde
euh et qu'en même temps
euh ils attendaient la seconde lecture
pour trouver un système qui
justement peut-être soit soit
moins moins fort parce que je je juste
pour vous expliquer la genunèse de la
discussion hein que je n'ai pas du tout
sollicité il y a donc aujourd'hui des
communes carencées qui touchent la DSU
certaines de manière très importante et
le débat était de savoir si ces
territoirees devait encore être aidé
malgré leur refus de rentrer dans les
obligations
triénale néanmoins la suppression la
suppression totale amène un impact
financier qui est très important et me
semble-t-il il faudra certainement
modérer ce sujet-là ou en tout cas le
l'affiner un autre débat qui ne relève
pas qui n'est pas apparu là mais qui a
été important dans le texte de loi et je
pense qu'il vaevenenir devant vous
plutôt en loi de finance c'est toute les
questions d'exonération de TFPB avec des
difficultés réelles donc je vous le dis
par avance parce que vous vous allez
peut-être déposer les mêmes types
d'amendements on a la même discussion
pour avoir discé Christian etkererte il
y a peu de temps nous allons d'ici les
discussions loi de finan on voudrait
organiser de travail avec les députés et
les sénateurs intéressés sur le sujet
parce qu'objectivement je pense qu' a
quelque chose qui ne fonctionne pas
actuellement sur cette exonétion ce qui
explique d'ailleurs les amendements
récurrents qui sont posés de part et
d'autrre on est tous les ans absolument
et il me semble en plus que on narrive
pas y compris à à renseigner d'un point
de vue financier ces questionsl donc il
y a eu beaucoup d'amendements là-dessus
ça ne ressort pas là du texte de loi tel
qu'il était mais c'est un débat qui me
semble est un sujet évidemment
évidemment
important
euh
sur sur le surloyer mais on y reviendra
dans le détail
euh quelqu'un a parlait de de de d'une
forme de prudence à adopter sur son
application et c'est en fait euh sur
quoi nous avons abouti dans le texte de
loi qu'on vous présente aujourd'hui
c'estd que la la la version présentée
par le gouvernement au départ était
beaucoup plus dur euh et après
discussion notamment lors des des
rencontres que j'ai eu avec les
associations de de locataires discussion
avec les élus qui a une volonté de
renforcer le dispositif mais aussi de
regarder très clairement très clairement
son impact après je le redis aujourd'hui
on est quand même on a gardé les
exemptions du surloyer notamment dans
pas mal de de de territoire et euh ça
reste un sujet aujourd'hui qui malgré
tout répond aussi à une question c'est
qu'au-delà d'un certain revenu et on
peut avoir un débat sur justement est-ce
que le logement social doit avoir ou non
des des des des plafonds de ressources
et jusqu'où euh et c'est la logique qui
avait été instaurée à l'époque mais
c'est vrai aussi que il y a aussi un
débat au sein des associations sur euh
est-ce qu'il est normal que des
personnes qui ont des revenus très euh
euh enfin qui dépasse fortement les les
les plafonds de loyer est-ce qu'il est
normal qu'elle puisse rester dans le
logement social quand il y a tant de
personnes qui demandent à y rentrer
c'est un débat politique c'est un débat
politique et philosophique et
euh et et c'est me semble-t-il un sujet
euh et c'est là-dessus que nous avons
voulu chercher euh notamment à trouver
en même temps le maintien du surloyer de
modération le surloyer il représente
aujourd'hui à peu près 1 million d'euros
euh de revenus pour pour les bailleurs
sociaux ça s'exerce essentiellement sur
les très grandes métropoles euh et euh
voilà et je vous l'ai dit il y a
actuellement à peu près 4500 personnes
qui sont concernées par cela euh
Christian Favi a parlé tout à l'heure de
sa PPL sur Grand Paris que j'ai été voir
tout à l'heure justement avant cette
audition euh moi je partage la question
que dans ces grands programmes
d'infrastructure et compris de mobilité
on puisse y compris s'assurer que autour
de ces grands de cette offre de
transport justement on est des logements
abordables la question c'est est-ce que
c'est vraiment du logement social je dis
cela par rapport à là où sont les gares
il y a quand même un certain nombre de
gares du Grand Paris qui vont être en
plein quartier politique de la ville en
plein PRU et donc moi mon souci et je
pense qu'on est à peu près sur la même
idée mon souci est pasant de savoir s'il
faut un pourcentage de logement social
chaque autaugard c'est plutôt est-ce que
on est sûr des prix de sortie en locatif
privé locatif social accession à la
propriété autour de ces gares et en gros
pour dire les choses très clairement
queil ait une vraie mixité de l'offre et
que ça soit pas simplement par exemple
des logements de standing ou du bureau
je pense que ça dépend vraiment des
quartiers il y a des endroit enfin je
pense à la gare à HN sousbois notre
sujet est pasant le logement social
autour de cette zone par contre est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir produire du locatif
privé qui est au niveau de
l'intermédiaire ou un peu plus élevé
mais en tout cas qui répond aux besoins
et c'est là me semble-t-il une
discussion d'ailleurs qui n'est pas
qu'une discussion de loi c'est la la
vraie discussion du cahier deschargge
des logements qu'on va construire autour
de autour autour de ces gares mais me
semble-t-il cette réflexion qu'on a
actuellement dans un dans une métropole
où donc on développe une de transport
considérable me semble-t-il on l'aura
aussi dans d'autres métropoles à venir
autour de grands projets d'activité
économique où il faut semble-t-il qu'on
fasse attention au risque d'éviction des
des salariés qui ont des salaires
médians et qui aujourd'hui risquent
cette éviction si en effet on y fait pas
attention et là me semble-t-il c'est un
sujet euh
euh peut-être législatif mais aussi
évidemment politique et contractuel euh
j'ai noté la question des territoires en
veille qui sortent des des qpv alors en
sachant que euh on raisonne à l'échelle
des EPCI donc euh euh je et je connais
bien euh
votre votre coin et euh et en effet pour
des territoires comme le vôre je pense
même qu'il faudrait qu'on réfléchisse
quasiment à l'échelle départementale si
on veut voir régionale et la question
francilienne est en soit un sujet très
important et notamment dans votre
département avec des concentrations très
fortes dans certaines villes et des
retards encore important dans d'autres
et et je pense que notamment c'est cette
discussion là qu'il faut qu'on ait dans
les conférences intercommunales très
clairement très clairement pour
justement répondre à la question à la
question que que que vous posez
après semble assez
important dernière chose je pas répondu
à tout mais mar nous a posé une question
importante qui est la question du porté
à connaissance en effet des territoires
sur sur notamment les
euh les les données sur l'occupation
sociale euh donc aujourd'hui en fait ce
qui est inscrit dans dans le texte de
loi euh c'est justement avec en lien
avec l'Union sociale pour l'habitat de
anonymiser les données d'occupation et
donc l'État les anonymisera pour qu'on
puisse ensuite les donner au territoire
donc c'est-à-dire à l'ensemble des
territoires que pour que vous ayez
véritablement les données
d'occupation du logement social et c'est
le Jeep du SNE donc le Jeep qui gère le
système national d'enregistrement qui
pourra faire y compris les cartographies
et qui pourra faire s porter à
connaissance il y aura aussi les données
de la CAF on a eu un débat euh sur
lequel là j'ai un trou de mémoire sur
comment on a abouti mais qui se posa
aussi des questions sur les les les
informations liées au revenus euh au
revenus fiscaux on a tranché ça non on
n' pas réussi encore à aboutir mais donc
j'anticipe mais notamment de savoir quel
type de données on peut parce qu'on a
aussi des questions de secret fiscal à
répondre mais il y a eu tout un débat
sur savoir est- ce qu'on peut avoir les
données fiscales et quels dispositifs on
doit voir c'est des sujets sur lesquels
depuis la lecture à l'Assemblée on n'a
pas encore plus totalement aboutir mais
sur lesquels on va revenir enfin euh
pour répondre à la question de des
baisses de loyer donc le texte de loi
prévoit des des choses en effet sur le
le une nouvelle politique de loyer mais
au-delà de ça il y a en effet
aujourd'hui des territoires où il y a eu
par exemple des conventionnements en PLS
et les logements sont à des revenus trop
élevés par rapport par rapport au marché
il a été décidé l'année dernière la
baisse du taux commissionnement des
banques qui a permis de générer 170
millions qui vont être dévolu aux
organismes HLM pour pour les aider dans
leur politique de baisse de loyer nous
annoncerons au Congrès HLM le dispositif
en tant que tel et ça permettra
notamment me semble-t-il de répondre à
ces questions-l sur des logements qui
ont donc été financés par exemple en PLS
et on le voit des grands logement
notamment financés en PLS qui
objectivement arrivve à des niveaux de
de loyer qui sont qui sont trop élevés
et qui de fait sont vacants et qui pose
évidemment des gros problèmes de gestion
de patrimoine avec ses logements vacants
donc ça c'est c'est un sujet qui est en
dehors du texte de loi mais qui sont des
outils supplémentaires qui sont donnés
aux bailleurs dans les mois qui viennent
voilà en quelques mots je crois que j'ai
pas pu répondre à tout mais je pense
qu'on va avoir un débat long dans les
mois qui viennent mais effectivement
nous aurons l'opportunité d'échanger au
cours de la discussion du
texte qui normalement je le signale au
membre de la Commission devrait débutter
début octobre c'està-dire plus tard que
prévu nous avons conférence des
président ce soir et l'ordre du jour
devrait être fixé d'après les
informations dont je dispose qui sont
fiables le texte sur égalité citoyenneté
ne viendrait que à partir du 4 octobre
si ça correspond à un mardi en tout cas
un début de
semaine pour autant je le signale parce
que nous avons un ordre du jour très
chargé en ce qui concerne les travaux de
laacquisition spéciale rien n'est
modifié c'est-à-dire que il n'y a pas de
de trans faire d'une semaine à l'autre
des dates qui avaient été initialement
envisagé non d'abord parce que il y a un
point important c'est qu'il faut donner
du temps entre le moment où
euh les auditions sont faites en
commission spéciale où les travaux sont
menés pour ce qui concerne l'élaboration
du texte et l'examen en séance publique
trop souvent on découvre au dernier
moment le travail des commissions par
rapport qu'on a à peine le temps de lire
là écoutez circonstances font que nous
disposons du temps nécessaire du temps
quasiment réglementaire d'ailleurs et
donc nous allons
respecter la chronologie qui avait été
initialement envisagée et je vous
confème à ce titre que demain après-midi
nous allons recevoir à 14h15 Thierry
Repentin délégué interministériel à la
mixité sociale dans
l'habitat mes chers collègues madame la
ministre permettez-moi de vous remercier
au nom de l'ensemble des membres de la
commission spéciale au total la quasi
totalité des membres de la commission
spéciale ont été présents dans cette
hémicycle de la salle Médicis et
manifester leur intérêt par un grand
nombre d'interventions comme vous l'avez
souligné nons l'occasion d'en débattre n
prendrons le temps nécessaire
conformément à une tradition bien ancrée
au Sénat de façon à bien agir dans
l'intérêt général voilà merci encore
Madame le Ministre et merci mes chers
collègues
voilà pour l'audition d'Emmanuel k
l'ex-patron d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
et ministre aujourd'hui du logement qui
s'est donc exprimé devant les sénateurs
réunis en commission spéciale à
l'occasion de la préparation du projet
de loi égalité et citoyenneté la
ministre du Logement qui a défendu
toutes les mesures notamment en faveur
du logement social contenu dans ce texte
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site
publsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 16h30 pour SCNA 360 avec Delphine
Gérard très bonne journée sur les
chaînes
parlementaires